Breaking news. Okay, breaking news. Apparently, Pisco and Hutch
had another sort of blow up. >> So, I don't want to hear
any from you. Therefore, when Democrats in the future choose
not or leftwing people choose not to endorse a Democratic candidate
for >> Oh, Pisco is saying the same. Uh-oh. >> Did
this get a labbotomy recently? >> Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa. So, you say it's the height of irony. Should we condemn
Mom Donnie for not endorsing Kla Harris? Of course. Correct.
Yes or no? Yes or no? I don't think so. Oh, so we don't So you
don't have any smoke? So you don't have any So I want to hear
you. You don't have any smoke for Hassan for not directly endorsing
Kla Harris. That's right. >> Hassan [__] he
has
just said, >> "Oh my god, he's actually he's actually just
making him eat his own right now.
I apparently breaking news." Okay. Woo! Breaking news. Apparently
Pisco and Hutch had another sort of blow up. I've just been told
this is good. So
Keem Jeff, they have a whole caucus, right? We've talked about
this before. They have moderates, they have liberals, you know,
and they're they're leadership happens behind the scenes and
they're not the most public-f facing people. So I think as the
shutdown happens, these next 24 hours, they're going to get a
lot of attention. And by the way, this is the first time Hakee
Jeff has met with Donald Trump. And you know, there could be
some dynamics there that we haven't seen play out yet. >> Is
it going to be televised their >> They are. No, they already
had a meeting. They came out front of the White House today and
talked. And by the way, Donald Trump cancelled their meeting
last week. Last Thursday, they were supposed to have a meeting.
Chuck Schumer, Jeff, and Trump. He canceled it. Said, "What's
the effing point? There's no reason to talk to them." Over the
weekend, he capitulates and they had a meeting today. So, he's
already taking an L. Can we can we put on the can we put put
some points on the board for like caution though? Like uh can
does anybody can you guys explain like how could Trump possibly
manipulate a government shutdown to do really bad cuz I keep
hearing about this. >> Well, this was like the initial
government shutdown. The reason Schumer didn't want to do it.
It was he said that they would use this to seize more power and
I wasn't really, you know, sure I understood what he was claiming
but like that they would erode certain industries. They'd fire.
So I mean they're going to they >> Is the video quiet for
you guys or just >> Is the video quiet? Hold on. I'll I'll
open it up and see. >> Employees this time, right? The
the people that are low a bunch of government workers. Um I don't
super understand how this is different that time. No one's really
>> Okay. So uh good that we did the quick rundown of the
shutdown, right? Since they're on the topic of the shutdown and
apparently that's how it comes about. So >> communicated
that to me. Can someone >> It's not No, no. It's not different
at all. only this time, I suppose, um, you know, the Supreme
Court is giving him more and more wins in these in some of these
outrageous like shadow docket opinions where they're not even
giving the reasoning and they're kind of just letting Trump win
on the status quo or on some standing or or procedural or something.
Um so like I I understand that the like that aspect of it might
change the courts are giving less and less wins or really just
one court the Supreme Court uh all the other intermediate appellet
courts and um you know the trial courts they're doing a great
job but the Supreme Court's really just up in terms of upholding
the rule of law maybe that's different but in terms of the dynamics
in like the worst of all possible worlds military coup scenarios
all that it's the same exact stuff it's the same exact what I'm
concerned about though are some of the reports some of the reports
that Schumer has lost the confidence of his caucus I'm seeing
at reported. I'm seeing reports that, you know, they might do
the a temporary stop gap bill and Schumer might
I'm seeing report. >> So again, this is like big I think
like Pisco has wanted these people to fight harder in Congress
for like a long time. I I actually this might be starting from
a different place. I think this could be from Hutch usually goes,
"Ah, what are you going to do? I don't know how you could fight
any harder. Like what are you we don't have the votes. What are
we supposed to do?" Right? And Pisco's like, "No, you just do
everything you can. Every procedural he be Mitch McConnell, okay?
Do every procedural thing you can to obstruct >> these
people, right? >> They would and they have. Obama didn't
get his last uh Supreme Court seat because they with no power.
They they should not have had the power. They found the power
and prevented it. If you have the the the ability to with the
rules to force them to like make some sort of consensus to actually
have a governing body that works together and not works as like
opposing sides. Yeah. You make them do that. >> Well, especially
when they're doing it to you, right? You like unfortunately if
you had some Yeah. You that those are the rules. You got to play
by the rules as they're being played, right? I've been preparing
for this day for a couple weeks with uh Josiah on Twitter like,
"Okay, I'm preparing for like the depression that will be in
two weeks because the Democrats won't do it." >> Oh, has
he been saying it the whole time? Like you have to you have to
>> not the whole time, but um there was like an Ezra Klein
video just talking about how much it's important that Democrats
understand that they need to do something, >> do anything,
>> take this opportunity to hold the line. Every single
damn influencer is Gavin uh Gavin McKinnus right now. Get off
your hat. Do something. >> Do something. >> Punches
the mic. >> I think I think that's how this is going to
devolve is I think it's going to be along those lines. I I think
>> said no. >> There was reporting that >> 710
day bill. No. >> Well, that contradicts reporting that
I saw a headline for today which is was it Axio which said that
Schumer was going around and asking Democrats if they'd be >> Yeah.
I don't know if you know more about that than I do, but >> well,
I think he had a press conference with Aake Jeff like two hours
ago. I think he said no to a question about it there. But I I
think Schumer has to fight. He's got to demand and he he can't
back down. So, I just don't see a world in which he does. >> What
do you guys
>> Go ahead. Go ahead. >> Well, I was going to say,
what do you guys think of uh Destiny's floated the demand of
having Donald Trump comm um uh >> I'm sorry, what? >> Hutch,
why? Hutch, why? uh condemn
>> touch nothing. It's >> like all political violence
and not just leftwing political violence. I don't know. I kind
of think that's interesting. Like >> they thought that
would actually do something, but >> No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no. Hutch is totally brain right now. And I It really
sucks. Okay.
Don't be convinced by anybody that you have to say, "I won't
disavow violence until you do." Right? You don't have to do that.
You don't have to make it seem like you're saying well I want
you to be scared so you like you don't have to do that. You could
just say uh obviously I disavow violence is really disgusting
that this Trump person won't and Republicans won't. It's like
they are the ones who are pushing this constantly and then just
fight them on that. Right. You don't have to you don't have to
say I no I I I'm not going to disavow. >> I just even if
you felt like that's a good point. Why would that be a good point
to make by prefacing it with, hey, this person who
uh kind of has dropped all political civility and has antagonized
and maybe ridiculed and mocked those who have lost their lives
to political violence? Here's what he thinks. And I think that's
a good point. Like, can you make the argument outside of referencing
a really controversial
>> Yeah. Or like, can you just make it Yeah. I it's not
even like a >> if you thought it was a good point, you
wouldn't you wouldn't marry it with this >> Well, I think
it's not even that they're controversial to me at least. I think
that's that's like a escalating factor. Just say the idea, right?
Like you you should have heard the idea, thought about the idea,
seen if it makes sense with like your principles, right? And
then gone, "Oh, that's clearly what we should do." Instead of
going >> instead of taking the idea you know is unpopular,
putting it on the person you know is unpopular who said it, right?
It's like the most way of of having this conversation because
it's like, "No, no, no. I I'm saying like maybe this other guy
that I totally disavowed for having this opinion, maybe he's
like a little more." It's like, "Why? Why the [__]
would you need to do that?" >> This is the person who cites
a really good idea from a book that he can't >> Oh, I hate
this concept so much. >> And he barely remembers the name
of the >> When people do it, it makes me lose my mind when
people do this. Like, it's >> like citing it incorrectly.
That's And it It's exactly like that. like they're trying to
site something from a book that they sort of perused once and
they use the terms or they use something from that book incorrectly
in a way that's so infuriating to somebody who read it >> and
then you ask them and they're like just read this book. >> Well,
you disagree with the person who wrote the book. >> Don't
don't bring the [__] up. >> Don't bring it
up to me if you can't make the the argument through and
>> Right. If I start asking questions, all of a sudden
I have to read the book to figure out why I'm wrong. I probably
shouldn't ever hear it come out of your >> Yeah. But but
I just saw he was on a segment on the news today and I didn't
want to bring this up, you know, but you made it organically
and
>> okay, I'm just gonna I I hate to put this on Pisco,
but Pisco is actually >> I just saw he was on today and
I didn't want to bring this up, you know, but you made it organically
and and essentially he kind of talked about like what my strategy
is and he's like >> just he's just like can you guys are
you guys serious right now? Pisco just shook his head and like
discussed he's like >> he should shake his head. Like why
why >> why do you have a member of the circus right below
you on your own podcast? Like could Soy Pill look any less serious?
How are you going to be like a fairly conventionally attractive
male
and do a political podcast
and you want to sit there with a boy toy helicopter hat and what
looks like a pickle in your
>> That's pickle Rick. He should go he should go scratch
a couple of the teeth and then they could call him Pickle Wick,
too. >> Pick a Wick. >> Like, look, if every single
time this happens, something happens. Deeply unserious, but I
think that's like a brand. And I'm I'm okay with like I'm okay
with the brand. >> I'm not okay with it, >> but I
I'm okay with it. But I think it's uh you got to have good ideas,
right? You got to be you got to be on point. You can't have the
brand of like like trying to look like you don't care and then
be a
reason the reason House gets to show up without his coat on is
because he gets results. Okay? He's like a he's like totally
awesome at his job. >> It is quite the opposite for me.
If you look like that, if that is your brand, you better never
say anything intelligent. You better never be making a good argument.
I don't want to ever hear anybody reference Soy Pill made a really
good point about what the Democratic Partners do. Like, no. Please
get the out of here and go to something
>> Okay. Uh I disagree, but I that's a fine opinion to
have. I uh I read a book about this once >> and wear some
goddamn sleeves >> and say the the left wing has to out
to the right wing. Uh they have to say, "Oh, like you know, we
disavow all public violence. Oh, like we don't support this guy
who did something against the right." And this is then taken
by the right-wing as look, they're guilty because they're admitting
fault. And I just don't see how that somehow reconciles with
the idea that well, if I won't disavow political violence, if
I if I go on TV and say the worst possible thing that can get
clipped and and amplified, this is not going to be taken by the
people that are going to take and say that this is guilt. Uh
how that at all is going to drive more people to the the cause
of oh actually yeah, the >> Okay, I actually do I have
to rewind here? I don't think I heard anything he like I don't
understand. Um,
>> you saw he was on a segment on the news today and I
didn't want to bring this up, you know, but you made it organically
and and essentially he kind of talked about like >> lower
the music >> what my strategy is and he's like hold on.
Oh, it is quite loud. There we go. >> Look, if every single
time this happens, something happens and they the the left wing
has to out to the right wing. Uh, they have to say, "Oh, like
you know, we disavow all politic violence. Oh, like we're we
don't support this guy who did something against the right."
And this is then taken by the right-wing as look they're guilty
because they're admitting fault. And I just don't see how that
>> wait what >> reconciles with the idea that well
if I won't disavow political violence if I if I go on TV and
say the worst >> I can't I can't say I disavow political
violence cuz that's right-wingers go look they're guilty. >> Why
would that be a why wouldn't like what's actually possible thing
that can get clipped and amplified? this is not going to be taken
by the people that are going to take and say that this is guilt.
Uh how that at all is going to drive more people to the the cause
of oh actually yeah the president should be the one disabowing
violence. I I think it's completely ridiculous but okay soy pill
is about to say or what he's saying here a little different than
what I heard in chat. What he's saying here is uh I think that's
a totally message.
Right. Obviously, if I say if I say, "No, no, no, I'm gonna disavow
or sorry, I'm not going to disavow violence because I want you
to be scared because I want you to put pressure on Trump." That
doesn't get more people to go, "Oh, like Trump should disavow
violence." Actually, that makes everybody go, "Oh, you're trying
to threaten me. [__] you." Obviously, yeah, if we
could somehow like call use the shutdown, which is going to affect
everyone, and say, "Hey, we'll we'll give you the money if you,
you know, disavow terrorism, which you have not done. You've
not turned down the temperature." I think that's a good idea.
Yeah, the guy in Michigan, the guy in Michigan who who uh shot
up that Mormon church and burned it to the ground. Uh he was
a Mormon who was posting like >> he was not Mormon. >> He
was not Mormon.
>> Why do you
>> He streamed all day, by the way. He streamed all day.
And I did he stream yesterday, too? >> How did he stream?
How did he stream and not figure this out? >> He was a
Mormon. He was a Christian. >> I've been told multiple
times he was Christian. Uh he hated Mormons. He thought Mormons
were the Antichrist. >> This is a fact that he was Mormon.
>> Wait, how? >> From what I read, he was a Christian.
Mormons uh also refer to as Christians, but many Christians also
view Mormons as like um Antichrist or >> so Iization
of it. >> I think I have a video here from the person.
So if he was a Mormon, he's not going to be he's not a Mormon
anymore. Converted and then left. Oh, >> so he wasn't born
a Mormon and he wasn't a Mormon because he hated the Mormon >> Wait,
so are you saying he was a Mormon or is a Mormon?
>> Oh, the this is the fact he was a Mormon. Okay.
>> Yeah, he's but he's not a Mormon anymore. And like he
he clearly he had beliefs that were clearly not of somebody who
like was raised in the Mormon faith at all. >> Right. You
don't think Mormons are the Antichrist? Yeah. Yeah. You would
have to know about Mormons to then later realize that it's such
a like blasphemy against what the Bible is for other
denominations of uh Christianity. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Charlie
Kirk stuff on his social media. So, it seems like a Trump sign,
but it said stop. There was a stop sign under the Trump sign.
So, that might be interpreted as Trump stop, which if you reverse
in your head is stop Trump, which means she's anti-MAGA. Maybe
Trump's top
>> Schumer has to get something tangible and it's got to
>> Okay, I respect IRI for this. He's like, "These guys
are getting off topic. Talk about the shutdown." I watch C-SPAN
all day. Talk about the shutdown. >> Some extension of
the ACA subsidies or some reversal of the big beautiful bill
Medicaid cuts. It's got to be has to. And they're going to There's
no like some commitment from Trump to make a statement. No way.
I I I don't know what the representation is if if uh if that's
Steven's ask or whatever. I respect where Steven is coming from
with respect to like the um the both sides not having to do it
in order to get to the you know the the karma heaven or whatever.
So I totally understand that angle of it. I just don't think
it's appropriate for this negotiation and it's something that
Trump would go back on and u I just can't imagine him being like
yes I'll condemn in exchange for money and here's my condemnation.
>> I don't think the point would be to >> I agree
with Pisco. What? >> I agree with Pisco and IRI.
It actually makes no sense that the government funding and the
negotiation for funding should have anything to do with
a statement or
uh memorandum about apologizing or condemning like terrorists
and political violence actually makes no sense. Maybe maybe actually
address the issues like IRA is saying about healthcare. >> Yeah.
I Okay, so they're saying this. Are they speaking hypothetically
or is there something there from Trump? Was that an actual thing?
>> They're making it sound like that's maybe Yeah, maybe.
So long as Trump says that he condemns political violence, then
us the Democrats will give you the
>> Why is that a trade? >> I'm Yeah, I'm just trying
to I was this just invented though? Like I'm sorry. I have not
seen If anybody has anything on this I feel it feels bizarre
to me. That would be really weird. And yeah, like >> well
because I think these things were going on last last week or
whatever. Congress will do this. They'll gather around. They'll
put stuff to a vote just to like declare a statement. I think
I forget. There's like a term >> statement or something.
Sure. Sure. >> They wanted to create a statement about
uh Ilhan Omar and that did not go through. They wanted to say
that she was like here under false pretense,
married her brother illegally or something. Like they do weird
through Congress for votes. >> All right. Um >> a
censure. That's what it is. >> Interesting. Okay. I weird
>> to necessarily like cuz >> it's just weird that
they got here. I don't know. >> But he knows he would never
do that. But but you know, you could necessar you could possibly
like generate some headlines there. Um >> yeah, it's just
to highlight how much he's not doing it because right now everyone's
like, well, it's you know, how can we hyperfocus on crazy other
things that have nothing to do with the president of the United
States? And this is a hey your life sucks right now cuz the president
won't turn the temperature down. Not hey we actually think the
president's going to change his mind because of that. >> But
it doesn't your life doesn't suck as much compared to your health
insurance premium going up 50. >> Yeah. That's
>> I I'm sorry. Oh man. >> Your life sucks because
Trump won't say this one statement. What >> people also
think that ma listen
the manga people as much as they're like kind of being held back
on the epste thing. It's not like they're not about it. It's
not like they don't want to know. It's not like there isn't still
a ton of public support to release all the Epstein files, right?
Just cuz Trump goes, "Hey guys, why do you care about this Epste
this creep? Why you focus on this?" They don't stop looking.
He doesn't quite have that power. He has a lot of power. But
even if he goes, "Oh, I disavow all violence." You think you
think a bunch of like right-wing crazies are going to go, "Oh,
right. I'm I should put my gun away. I was going to go do it,
but I'm going to put my gun away now." >> Clutch thinks
it'll generate some really good headlines.
>> Not even
apparently. He's over here just thinking about what the headline
will >> Apparently, and again, I can't I can't stress enough
that no matter what happened in Michigan,
the thing that happened was the biggest like one of the biggest
conservative influencers and power players in the Republican
party got gunned down in a totally like televised totally
uh recorded way that everybody could replay over and over again.
Trying to virtue signal for your side, the side that he wasn't
on based on his murder is really difficult to do. And I don't
think there's a single person in Congress capable of doing that.
Like they don't have the maybe maybe Obama could do it. I have
no idea. But it's like you you guys can't do it. So I wish they
would stop discussing things like this. >> When I saw that
on Sunday, I opened Twitter and before I saw it, I saw Erica
Kirk tweeted out early that morning, go to church, and I was
thinking this
>> this [__] >> cuz I don't even have
a church here or anything like that. Like I'm going to stay in
bed. And then I find out about a shooting and I'm like, was that
the was that the go? Did she just give like was that the memo?
>> You know how people were making up bizarre theories
like there was someone who was pointing at Charlie Kirk now type?
I'm already thinking of that in my inbed like did this just give
the green light on Twitter
go to church bam and then this drove into a church >> any
listen anybody who >> I'm becoming more conspiratorial
every >> anybody that doubts Christianity okay any any
schisms although I guess you can't really I don't know I'm sure
the problem is so I I kind of joke that like um JD Vance talked
about how this like Charlie's death was you know he's a martyr
for Christianity and Nick Fentes talked about how he got because
he was a Christian, right? He was preaching the word of God.
And then this guy goes, this guy who thinks like Mormons are
the Antichrist. Mormons think they're above Jesus. Mormons think
they're better than like the rest of the Christian faith. He
goes and shoots up a Mormon church. It's like, well, if you think
Christianity is under attack, you think the Mormons are doing
it. >> I could see how this might end up, you know, cracking
some wires. I don't know if we could say it's like JD's fault.
I don't think it's JD's fault. Like I but I'm like, okay,
clearly nobody's focused on just turning the temperature down
in all directions. They're all trying to seize like the current
moment for their political movement.
>> And that's what kind of >> they're not thinking
about what their words signal out. They they think that their
words mean nothing. >> And like the you just need the words,
the unequivocal words like violence is never right. Violence
is never for political motives. Violent never violence. Okay.
>> Never. But yeah, I I wish he would do that, but >> 60
bucks next year, you know what I mean? Like that is going to
impact everybody who has health insurance, which is way more
people than people impacted by political violence in my opinion.
Maybe you guys feel >> No, I totally agree. Like maybe
to the extent that it's important. I I you know anecdotally it
seems like political violence is going up and it seems like there
have been like multiple days of like uh shootings and and so
if I was just like testing the air like my intuition is that
it's going up but even then it's like this is not affecting most
people. This is a fraction of a fraction of something you know
here's the messaging and they the Democrats have started to say
it. Hakee is saying it. Schumer saying it. This is Trump shutdown.
Trump is the president. They control the House. They control
the Senate. Your average American does not understand that you
need seven votes from the Democrats in the Senate because you
need 60 votes to get a bill across the finish line and there's
only >> Yeah, I I figured that was um the funding resolutions
probably required 60. That's why it's like a joint thing.
>> 53 Republicans. All people know is Trump's the president
and there's a shutdown and there was no shutdown when Biden was
president. That's what I think the the message is going to be
as we move forward. That's what the media is going to say, too.
I'm not I'm I'm mad
>> that's what got Trump the first time, his first year
in office, um when that shutdown was rising up and they were
trying to get rid of the child tax
>> He had tweets saying
when there's a government shutdown under Obama, that's Obama's
doing. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um
I do think so. Yes. I think the there's like a couple different
arguments there.
uh when it was like the previous time I understood why they sort
of thought a shutdown might work in their favor. I don't know.
I don't know if it flips. I think the unfortunate thing is is
Green Pepper just said it. I think I think Democrats end up owning
the shutdowns cuz there's a big part of the Republican party
who are just like, "Oh, the government's not signing checks.
Perfect." As stupid as that is. >> No, that's what you
think. >> It worked until they start paying for >> It
worked his first term. >> It worked his first term. So,
>> yeah. Yeah, I could see it. I think um >> we'll
see. >> Yeah, you just have to see how it ends up going.
>> that's why that's why Josiah Ezra Klene, they are gearing
up to make sure don't let them put this on Democrats. You need
to be prepared and you need to already be doing the like your
statements or whatever together, coordinating, figure out your
issue. The Republicans are doing this to you. This is Trump's
administration that's doing this to you. >> Yeah. Yep.
if this is this we might be veering into a different category
here topic here but I'm I'm more upset about uh Jeffrey's statement
uh regarding Adam
>> Eric Adams and here I'm I'm willing to join you actually
after many weeks of debating this now that Adams has actually
dropped out of the race now I think it is actually kind of valid
to ask for uh an endorsement from Jeff >> no doubt like
no no one's asking Jeff like if it were the case that Jeffy's
like I don't get into mayoral politics or whatever or he took
some kind of principle. I think it would be but whatever. But
when Mayor Adams >> Okay, so
this is interesting. I don't know if we all knew this guys, but
uh Eric Adams apparently suspended his campaign no longer. He's
like shut down. He's not seeking re-election. >> Um this
is a big deal cuz now is Zoron Mdani just running unopposed or
is is Quuomo going to jump back in? Cuz I think Quuomo knew he
couldn't win that him and Adams would split the vote. Is this
the sign of like Quuomo jumping back in now? I think Cuomo's
been in, but he's independent. And New York City has uh what
is it called? Choice voting.
Choice voting. So, you don't just vote for one person. You vote
in the order of who you like. Who's your first one? Who's your
second one? So, um
with Eric Adams dropping out, it most likely this is to mean
my voters are going to go to Quomo. We want it to be tighter.
I don't want to split up the moderate. Yeah, >> I don't
want to split up the moderate vote, so I'm dropping out because
this Mani guy, uh, he's seeming to gain a lot of traction and
it looks like it's going to be his. But something that bothered
everybody in New York City from the start is that this Jeffre
person has not put his hat behind anybody. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Hear
not. And like there's a well it's it's bizarre because Zora Mdani
is the Democratic Party nominee for this mayoral race. >> You're
the Democratic
you're the house minority speaker. House minority uh what is
it? Is it House Minority Speaker or House Minority Leader? Leader.
Leader. House Speaker is the person. Okay. Yeah. House minority
leader. You're the House minority leader or the Democratic party.
Why don't you endorse the Democratic candidate in your state?
And the answer is the a lot of people are trying to pull away
from Mani over his politics, right? The the because Mamani, trust
me, Mani's got pictures chilling with Hassan, eating some Indian
food in the middle of NYC. >> Absolutely ridiculous. Cuomo
is such a clown for pulling up pictures of him and
>> He's such a clown.
>> Because how is that how is that the the dig? Here's
here's mom Donnie dining with this controversial
uh influencer, this controversial streamer. Sorry, that kind
of got a lot of Republicans elected.
>> Uh, sure. Sure. >> Influencers, content creators
who really aren't running for office that say really edgy. Sorry.
Every side's got them. You're an unserious person if you're holding
him accountable to what this influencer said like seven years
>> Uh, it'll be interesting. just because it's the um it
is the quote, right? It's the quote they use against him every
time. So, we'll get to see how much America or sorry, New Yorkers
have moved on from 911 to any extent. If they'll be like, "Well,
this guy who once had dinner with the mayoral candidate said
America deserved 911.
>> They're over it. They don't give a [__]
about Rudy Giuliani was supposed to be the country's mayor. They
don't give a [__] about him anymore. Doesn't matter
what he sought through cuz he was the mayor throughout 911, right?
He's the person who handled it. Rudy Giuliani. >> They
used to love Trump in New York City. Now it's Trump.
>> they used to love you, Cuomo. What the did you do over
co now it's Cuomo?
How about stop worrying about the edge lord that Mumani sat down
and had lunch with? Stop worrying about that and address why
you are so unlikable in your own state. >> What's going
on? Uh if we are to believe what is it Adam Adam Freriedeland
Adam Freeland said listen the people everybody the people they
love Zora Mani okay they don't care that he's they don't care
that he's like I think he is Muslim right I think he is actually
>> New York saw what the the hate that happened after 9/11
they saw what that did to the people around them to their neighbors
to their friends throughout school they are not anti-American
right they love this country. They were attacked for this country.
You think that they hate this country if they're behind Mumani?
>> No. I mean, I don't >> I think Cuomo wants to
say that, but he he better say that with his whole chest. Hakee
Jeff, >> never say that with this. >> Hakee, you
better say with your whole chest. New York City is anti-American
cuz they voted for this dude, right? Cuz you're waiting this
long to get behind them. You must you must think something about
those New York City voters.
>> And so, yes. And I think the reason uh well I I agree
with you entirely, but they will never say it with their whole
chest. There's a reason they're playing playing it so tight that
they're playing it so close. >> They're hoping that they
can >> they're doing the Trump playbook, right? The Trump
playbook. What he tried to do to Obama? They're doing that to
Zoran Mani, but they're Democrats, so they don't want to make
it look like that.
>> They don't want to say, "Oh, you know, Zoron, you got
a birth certificate, buddy? You got a Can we Can we check? Can
we Are we sure you were born here? You Zoron? I've never That
doesn't sound like a biblical name to me. Okay. >> I feel
like that's what they're trying to do pretty clearly. >> Sorry,
Hakee Jeff. Uh,
no one's going to forget what you did here.
No one's going to forget. >> I think they'd forget if he
if if he steps up and endorses pretty quickly. Also, I don't
know why Eric Adams Maybe he's friends with Eric Adams or something.
Maybe he's campaigned with him in the past. I wonder why Eric
Adams would be the big differentiator. Right. >> But that's
also concerning that you would put your your friendship or you'd
put your
you liked working with Eric Adams over what the voters want.
>> Yeah. Some nonical tie. >> Eric Adams has a couple
of indictments behind him. A couple of uh are you committing
fraud? Are you enriching yourself through your mayoral uh whatever
what do you call it? Tenure. Did you take money from government
officials? How the you call how are they scrutinizing Mumani
and Eric Adams might have taken money bribes or whatever from
Turkey government officials. >> Yeah. I don't I also don't
know if that's the only place. I think he got offered or he's
being offered like a
some post somewhere else like they're basically trying they've
been trying to bribe him out of this position for quite a while.
I think >> bribe him out. I thought they were trying to
bribe him to get them to do his bidding while he was in this
>> Oh, they were both. I think now they also want him.
>> I think they want Comey. Sorry, not Comey. Quomo versus
>> Mani. I think that's what they want. Yeah, got >> I
think that's what they want. So, all right, let's uh let's keep
going here. They're basically talking about Jeff >> endorsing
MD or he took some kind of >> strangely Hutch saying that
>> principal. I think it would be but whatever. But when
Mayor Adams,
an indicted mayor who was taking bribes from the Turks and who
did a corrupt deal
Oh, do you pre-watch?
>> No, I just actually read
write read about his indictments. >> I know with Donald
Trump in exchange for greater ICE enforcement. Understand what?
Like everyone, we're fighting ICE, right? In the metaphoric sense,
and the political sense and you know, demal violence, but like
we're fighting ICE. ICS is like the enemy of the American people
in my opinion and that is not okay. Like we're allowing and we're
saying that it's you know he has a good like you don't even mention
the fact that he cooked up this deal. The fact that he's a corrupt
mayor in your statement you're like oh yeah he he did a pretty
good job. That is disgraceful. That is disqualifying in the era
of >> Wait wait wait. Did Jeff Oh, what did Jeff say? Hold
on before we get further into this statement. Embassy mayor We
got to pull up this. What was this statement? What is this statement?
Also, I think did I think we watched the Eric Adams thing. The
only thing I could think watching that Eric Adams statement.
Okay. The only thing I could think is this put himself on the
wall in a wig and say it was his mom. That's literally all I
could think. Hold on. >> Can you pull up the photo >> I
did not see this. Jay- Sock just like comes into the room like
this guy
>> This guy mom look like him in a wig. Yeah, he like has
a picture of her, brother. He's He's trying to trick all of us.
That's crazy. That's nuts.
>> I'm not fooled. >> How did he think he was going
to get away with this? He walks down the stairs with a picture
of his mom, and it's not his mom. He's like, "This is He's like
getting bribed. Okay, he went to Bohemian Grove. They made him
put on the dress, do the humiliation ritual, and now he's putting
this picture out there, and he's like, "This is my way of getting
out, guys." Okay, I'm show I'm showing I'm showing the picture
they took. All right. Try to get out. >> Not all black
people dress up like >> Yeah. No. >> Sorry, dude.
His mom has massive forearms. Okay. Holy [__] Is
she a sailor or >> No, that's from cooking. >> The
cooking. Okay. All right. All right. >> Dude, he's not
fooling me. He's not fooling me. Okay, hold on. We'll we'll watch
his uh or we'll read this real quick. Uh, Eric Adams, who served
courageously and authentically for decades as a member of the
NYPD, the New York State Senate, in Brooklyn Burough Hall, and
as our 110th mayor, Jeffrey said in a statement reported by multiple
media outlets. During his time in office, violent crime is down.
The building of affordable housing units is up, and New York
City has recovered from the CO9 pandemic. Adams, New York City's
mayor since 2022, exited the race less than a month before the
vote early voting begins. His departure sets up a three-way race
between Democratic nominee Zora Mandani, Republican nominee nominee
Curtis Siwa, and former New York Governor Andrew Cuomo, who's
running as an independent now. Is there no like Usually there's
a what? A non It's not a non-compete. It's a loyalty pledge,
right? Does New York City do the New York City Democrats not
make people like sign that? Cuz what the is going on here? Why?
How can you run in the primary, get your ass blown out, and then
go, "Well, actually, I'm going to run independent now." Is is
Andrew Cuomo just like taking every page of his campaign from
the Trump campaign directly?
This is what people thought Trump was going to do as sour grapes
after losing the Republican nomination. He ended up winning,
but I like usually the contingent on you running in the primary
is like signing a loyalty pledge saying, "Well, I'm not going
to run against the candidate you put in." It's very weird to
me that you wouldn't actually do that. Um,
let's see here.
New York City's mayor. The incumbent has had been running for
re-election as an independent since April. In September 2024,
he was indicted on bribery, campaign finance, and conspiracy
charges. The case was dismissed by a federal judge in April at
the Justice Department's request. So, the corrupt Trump administration
just dismissed the case for no reason,
right? No reason at all. >> How lucky. >> Adams,
dude, it's so it's so gross. and that this and between this and
the Tom Hman thing, dude, it's stupid. Anyway, Adams reportedly
met with White House White House special envoy Steve Wickoff
earlier this month. Wait, Steve Wickoff. That's not the guy with
the glasses, is it? Was Hold on. Steve
Wickoff. No, that's not who I thought it was. I'm thinking of
who is the Who is the Minister of the
It's not Minister of Finance. Who is the cabinet person in charge
of the economy? Who is who is uh Besson or Lutnik in the last
administration? Guy big glasses. Took a lot of flights. Took
a lot of luxury trips.
No, no, no. Not Besson. I'm not thinking of Besson. Steve. Steve.
Steve. Steve. Steve. Steve. >> You sh me. >> I don't
even remember what they call him. No, no, no. It's not Wickoff.
It's not Wickoff. Uh, I'll find it later and you guys will think
I The way I think is weird because I can't describe it. Okay.
Minutuchin. Steve Minutuchin. That's who I was thinking of. I
was like, "Wait, is that Steve Minutuchin? is like backing government
but no it's Steve Wickoff okay as is the case in any major city
there are challenges that remain so I think I think usually I
think because soy
but did he really not me like you're you're basically like giving
this guy a big sendoff when he is leaving in disgrace
right this is like this is like a Republican after January January
6th being like well Trump served well he did great you know that
got a little tough there at the end but He, you know, his presidency,
we we liked it, right? It's like you're leaving out some major
some major infraction that that should color this administration
for you, should color this tenure for you, and it's not making
it weird. Anyway, let's uh let's continue on. I had to go see
what Pisco was singming about. I had no idea, but it was just
a very glowing sendoff for Eric Adams to not call out. >> Oh,
wait. That's right. Pisco's in New York City.
>> Okay. So, you know, he would know the same infuriating
that I do if you follow all of the terrible in the city. >> Which,
first of all, the up train. And then second of all, Cuomo, cuz
anybody knows that in New York City there's like this this $25
million
uh a billion dollar $25 billion development deal for New York
City. They're like to put up stuff like affordable housing and
um fixed infrastructure and what have you. You know what they
spent it on? >> What's that? They built a luxury mall in
Manhattan and they built a schwarma looking staircase like a
$25 million staircase just for tourists. Just you walk up and
you walk down. There's nothing but a [__] staircase
there. And it looks >> like an art project or something.
>> It's a art piece. >> Oh,
cool. >> Instead of
more housing, homes and maybe useful buildings. Not not a luxury
mall that basically had to get shut down as soon as CO hit. A
lot of people were angry about that. >> Is that the mall
that's over Grand Central? One of the >> It's in Hudson
Yard >> cuz I saw
I think about >> Grand Central. >> There was some
mall that sent people into Grand Central Station. It was like
a part of some big controversy in New York, but I don't think
it's the same >> Anyway, we can deal the fact that he's
a corrupt mayor. In your statement, you're like, "Oh, yeah. He
he did a pretty good job." That is disgraceful. That is disqualifying
in the era of Trump to not call out and he was weak on him before
too because he didn't call on him to resign when it was clear
he was corrupt when it was clear he was cooking up a deal with
Tom Hman. Tom Hman who was also taking bribes $50,000 in bills
before the 2024 election in in exchange for the promise of contracts
after the election related to the border wall and bills in a
cava bag or whatever. In a in a food bag. >> Yes, in a
[__] cava bag. Looney Tune and
>> Like that's that's when you know there's like no chance
that he thought he was taking legitimate payment for legitimate
services rendered, right? You don't take a bag a grocery bag
full of cash and think, "Oh yeah, that's a normal transaction."
They're keeping that off the books. Did he pay taxes on that?
I actually think there's a decent chance he didn't get to keep
it or they might have like stopped him and and pulled it back
right away. So bad. So spare me on this. That is weakness of
the highest order. And it shows me that Jeffre isn't made for
this moment. In addition to all of his cringess, the dude is
just cringe. Listen to him talk for like 10 minutes. To me, it's
it's cringe all the way down. And and Schumer has passed his
time. It's time for new leadership at the Senate level, at the
House level. That's my take on it. It's been my take for a while.
And this recent Mayor Adam statements only further cements it.
>> I'm going to be the last man standing to >> what
what's position going to be? Surely he won't totally stand with
the Democrat politician in every single scenario for the thousand
sorry thousand for the millionth time in a row. I'm going to
be guys. I'm I'm going to give a crazy take here. You'll never
expect this. I stand with the House Minority Leader as I have
in every other case that's ever come up about Hakeem Jeff. I
stand with him once
>> Defending Jeff, not endorsing Mom Donnie. I don't give
a [__] because he's got to control a caucus full
of moderates. Control of the house goes through people like Marie
uh glu gluesome camp whatever Perez like th this is he's got
to walk a a fine line here. I saw the statement too and I was
a little takenback by it. But uh >> okay
like I don't even know about I don't know about endorsing mom
Donnie but you you let this guy walk when he's like totally corrupt
when he is like getting favors from the Trump admin
dropping his corruption cases.
>> Yeah, but that is that's Trump's people letting him
walk know. Or are you saying >> I'm saying is as Hakee
Jeff just because he was a Democrat just because you liked him
maybe when he was a politician there. You're just going to let
him skate. You're going to let you're going to not say anything.
You're go, "Oh, this guy did so great." >> Bro, the reason
he's walking away is because he's corrupt. >> Doesn't that
make you feel like Hakee is compromised in some way as well?
>> Could be. Yeah, could be. Could it's not indicative
of good moral character? For >> Um, you know, I don't think
it matters. Again, I don't think it matters. I want to push back
because I feel like there's a political calculation here because
I think that if Cuomo were to beat Mani,
number one, I feel like that would exac like really greatly exacerbate
the divisions that we're currently seeing within the party. And
number two, uh it would make the entire party I think look really
bad. There there's there's no good outcome here in my opinion
because let's say that um Jeff comes out and endorses mom Donnie.
Well, you were late. Why'd you take this long? Right. What if
he comes out and endorses Cuomo? Wait, we'll just let me get
it all out. What if he endorses Cuomo and Quuomo loses? Now he
looks like a jerk and everyone memes on him and no one takes
him seriously. What if he endorses Cuomo and Quuomo wins? >> How
can you How can you endorse an
I think if you if you were to endorse an independent, you would
look like you would look like a total just because you're the
House minority leader. You're supposed to be the young leadership,
the next generation for the Democrats, and you're going to come
out and endorse a guy running against the person who won your
primary. What? Like, at at best, you have to shut the [__]
up. Like, that's that's the most you can do for other people.
And to me that sounds like
you you genuinely believe that the New York voters and the New
York Democrats
have lost the plot. >> Yeah. Right. You're saying you >> you
should abandon you should unregister as a Democrat. If you feel
like your your state, the voting base of your state, the most
populated area of your state, you think that you don't align
with their choice, you probably don't align with that party.
No. >> I Yeah. I think basically like there's no way to
do that as a New York state official, as a leader of the Democratic
party at a at a federal level. Uh national level. I think you
say national level. I say federal cuz I'm Canadian, >> it's
federal. >> Okay. Federal level. So yeah, like obviously
you're cutting against the will of the party. Why the people?
Not even the party, but the the people.
>> Yeah, it would be crazy. So yeah,
>> Cuomo. He's not going to do that. you I mean you say
that and but what if he doesn't take what doesn't what if he
doesn't weigh in at all and he doesn't endorse anybody now he
looks weak. There's no good option here in my opinion. Um and
I think he's he's ever
>> I think you can endorse no one and not look weak. You
endorse no one, you don't look weak. What you end up looking
like is the Pokemon Ditto.
>> I'm I'm gonna compliment the person who was just in
office and I'm going to remain blank until you guys put one in
office. I'm just here to go with what you guys have done >> a
little bit, but like his party already picked. He He only has
one option. He only ever had one option. And it like I get the
>> not not necessarily true. There are plenty of people
who have been supportive and they um they vote along with the
Democratic party even though they're registered independent.
>> You don't want to cut that bridge off by just just playing
your party side. >> And I understand that. But I'm saying
in my opinion, you you're as a leader, I I don't think you I
think you say like I think you weakly endorse you say you could
say Mani's the the person the people chose. I endorse the Democratic
candidate. That's that's what you could >> Now, let me
ask you this because that is something that you could say. He
won the primary, but what if you feel like the only reason he
won the primary is because the majority moderate vote
was split. And so the primary that got through is actually a
minority voice that just unifies a lot better. >> You could
actually know that, right? Do they publish the results of like
the like do you get to see >> do you get to see the split
of the rank choice voting? Is it rank choice for the nominee
as well? I think it is. I'm pretty sure. >> I think it
should be. So, I I wonder because you could probably just know
who people's like second or third choice was. And I do wonder
if it was like splitting of the because technically if it's ranked
choice, it shouldn't matter if it's like you shouldn't be able
to split the vote, right? Like people if if it's moderates and
they go, you know, Adams or Quomo and then Mom Donnie.
>> Uh M Donnie had 43.5,
Quomo had 36.5.
How much did does Eric Adams even factor in? Oh, well, I don't
know if I don't know if Eric Adams ran in the primary. I for
some reason I want to say, did he drop out of the primary? >> I
think he only entered in as an independent after the fact. >> Yeah,
he didn't even run in the primary. So, yeah, he didn't he didn't
run in the
>> yeah, even New York Times uh reported that it was ranked
choice voting that really helped Mani take it. >> Well,
by a substantial margin. He actually he literally beat just on
the first round, just on who you chose, he beat Quuomo's final
score. It was close, but he barely beat Quuomo's final score.
If you just look at before he even gets the rank choice bump.
So, he actually just his number one from the first round, he
has 469,642
votes. Cuomo has 443,000.
>> Now, add in independents and add in Republicans who
are not like your southern Republican conservatives. They are
your northern Republicans. They're like your Chris Christie Republican
that is pretty fine with moderate Democrats.
>> For a ranked choice voting, it's very possible Quuomo
could win this. So, it is probably it is probably a political
move to make no backing. It's just it sucks if you are a very
progressive
because you would want Hakee to support this person to make it
to make sure you get through because it is going to be
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Apparently, apparently Lander, the
guy in third, and Mumani also endorsed each other. Like basically
said, "Okay, after after me, vote for this guy." And so that's
why the big slide goes over to Mum Donnie is a lot of people
who were like further left of Mum Donnie maybe would have voted
for this guy. Where's this guy from? Although he might not have
been further left than Mom Donnie. I'm not totally >> Women
women love voting for Cuomo. Okay,
>> I don't know about that. All right, we're uh we're ready
to go back to this guy right here. Not endorsing the eye. So
we're discussing the Jeff Hakee Jeff lack of endor here in my
opinion. Um, and I think he's he's himself over by not endorsing
the >> if if he endorsed Manny. Now, I don't think that
would be like I don't think people would look poorly on. >> No,
I think it's the least bad option, but like it seems so politically
calculated and so when it was obvious from the start that this
is the guy you should have backed after the primary and >> you
know, Mumani wants the endorsement, right? So like and and Jeff
technically has that leverage, but you could argue that Mum Donnie
has the leverage now too cuz they're like Hok endorsed him already
and so it feels like he's got a little bit of wind at his back.
But like >> yeah, I don't know. Yeah, go ahead. >> Hokll's
New York state, you know what I mean? Like, this is New York
State politics, so she's got to work with the mayor. Again, I
look at Hakeem Jeff as he's he's national. He's got to, you know,
keep his caucus together. He can't represent one side more than
the other. And control of the house goes through those moderate
districts like MGP and Jared Golden. So, I think best case scenario,
he doesn't endorse him at all. He doesn't need his endorsement
to win, and he stays neutral. And then he's not associated with
him. I mean, let me let me challenge you, Pisco. What does Hakee
Jeff get out of endorsing Mum Donnie? >> I think that it
he's endorsing his job
>> I I think that he is >> this is by the way the
argument here it just mirrors the Hassan argument one to >> This
is got to have this opinion, right? Should we cut Hassan out
of the party? Well, we don't have to give him additional stuff.
if we don't have to give them like power in the party, but there's
no reason we should like absent any wrongdoing on their part,
excise them because they are like further left than our genuine
genu uh general constituency or our central uh moderate constituency,
right? If you want to court that vote, if you want any part of
that vote, then like you shouldn't be throwing them off. And
you don't change what you think is the best way to get elected
in the country. You just say, "Well, here are the things we allied
on. If you want to vote for us, here's what we allied on." Right?
And so Pisco is going to say like there's no reason to isue Manny
just because he's from a more leftleaning part of the country.
You don't have to issue. Yeah, I think there's no reason to ignore
him. There's no reason not to endorse him when he's the DNC candidate
in that mayoral race, right? There's no reason to ignore him.
You just make it clear like, hey, this guy's like further left
than me. Yeah, he doesn't have the same politics as me. You endorse
him because he's your candidate. He's a part of your party. >> Does
he not have the same politics as Hakee, though?
>> I don't know. >> For some reason, I think they
take his name. I think they take the things about him and imply
like he doesn't have the same positions as any Democrat should.
>> I think he probably has similar positions. What IRA
is saying is that Hakeem Jeff because he represents the whole
party. He's saying the same thing you did before and like you
kind of leave behind some of the moderate districts that they'll
say, "Oh, look, Hakeem Jeff endorsed like this crazy socialist
for mayor and people will use that to work against like he's
basically Nancy Pelosi right now, right? Like he is the new Nancy
Pelosi. He's the Dem House leader and
they think basically people will be able to run ads against him.
He's probably thinking of his like long-term political viability,
right? They're going to try to tie the socialist guy to him.
>> But that's that I think that >> you sign up to
allow that to happen to you when you run for the Democratic party
and when you allow this guy when you don't go and campaign hard
for somebody else in the in the primary. If you want if he campaigned
hard for Cuomo in the primary, which maybe he did, that's fine.
If you just want to say, "Well, now I'm not endorsing." Then
then it looks like you're just maintaining consistency. It's
like, "Oh, I'm not going to I'm not going to endorse this guy,
but I am going to let this happen." Or something, right? Just
never taking a stand. It seems weird to me, too. >> It
It does seem like there is no benefit, though. >> Um I
think the benefit is showing that you'll support that is that
the DNC will stand behind its candidates even if they aren't
following the federal because then why is anybody wanting to
run as like a Democrat if you you have no support from that party,
right? It's like, "Oh, I want to I want to be I want to win."
So, I win the DNC mayoral
>> right? And the DNC refuses to support me. It's like,
"Oh, well, why do why are you even running a nominee process
if the party isn't going to support the person who wins it?"
Like, if you're just going to say, "Oh, the people of that city.
We don't like their politics, so no federal support. We don't
we don't like you. We're not going to endorse your candidate
or whatever." Right? Like, oh, the DNC is actually going to put
their finger on the scale when they don't like the outcome. the
federal DNC is going to put their finger on the scale when they
don't like the outcome in this local race. >> I am actually
closer to the idea that Hakee should never have been given the
position that he's given. He should not be the new Nancy. If
if he cannot set the tone if he's worried about how using his
voice could possibly be used against him, you can't be in that
seat. Trump was not he was not worried a moment to throw his
voice throw his support behind Roy Moore the who is prowling
the mall >> stood on business for a
>> Jeff can't even stand out of business for a guy who
wants universal healthcare >> the the absolute state of
the Democratic party today >> and the lost and Trump still
believed he made the right choice that things would be better
with war my like that is somebody who is directing people. Hakee
is being directed. Stop. I I'm just I'm so unpleased with the
amount of people who are put in a position to be a
>> Yeah, dude. Uh 42XX put banned from the mall, too. He
was prowling on kids at the mall. They banned him from the mall.
They banned him from the mall >> and then they elected
him. They knew he was banned from the mall and they still elected
him. >> Stop hitting on these 14-year-olds at the mall.
No. Make me. Okay, I guess we have no choice. What the [__]
It's an odd conversation. possibly, you know, ingratiating the
members of the left who really are enamored by Mum Donnie. He's
pushing party unity at a time when we need uh, you know, emphatic
leaders who are charismatic. Um, so I think that it makes it
it gives him I think at least something bonafides with uh the
left to some extent at least. Um, so yeah, I think that it can
make his job easier and and what could it hurt? All he's doing
is endorsing the Democratic nominee as the leader of the Democrats
in the House of Representatives. I would expect him to endorse
Tom Suis. I would expect him to endorse Jared Golden. And so
what's the problem with the Democratic leader endorsing the Democratic
candidate?
There's there is a slight difference from from the Hassan thing.
Okay, a slight difference,
but I don't want to I don't want to talk about it yet. Pisco
is I think there is a difference here, right? I think there is
a difference in versus Zoron versus somebody in the center because
you're in the federal system. You are looking at federal elections.
You don't want to offend the people at the center. That's where
the bigger mass of people is. That's probably the calculus that
IRI will defend. That's the calculus most people will defend,
right? >> Also, IRI said national, so maybe that was the
right word to use. >> Yeah. Okay. All right. >> Well,
that's a no-brainer. >> What's the harm? >> Usually,
as far as I know, they're only endorsing his incumbents in the
House. the anything else he's not really involved in. So he's
only going to fight for incumbents in the House and that's it.
Like nothing else. He's not involved in anything else. >> And
this is a principled position. You think that? >> Well,
this is this is the standard. It's not principles.
>> Well, it's about getting
what's going to make his job easier. He's a national figure for
the Democrats. Does he want to be associated with Mom Donnie
on the national stage? I just I'm just saying. Does that help
him do his job? I'm not sure it does. >> Well, then what
is theation of I'm going to talk with mom Donnie? Yeah, go for
it. Pisco, I guess the ultimate question is because I'm still
on the fence about this. Obviously, I think you should endorse,
but like whether or not I I don't know, I can't see the future.
Does endorsing Manny kind of does sway does it does it um dissipate
this illusion or not illusion, but like a very big perception
that Democrats are feckless and not listening to their uh base
because obviously there is a much larger base than what you would
see on the internet, but there is a huge amount of people, the
same people that are enthusiastically going out and canvasing
for Amam Donnie, who are doing all this volunteering. the reason
he was able to get off without all this big, you know, corporate
um energy and saying, "Hey, can we help get those people into
the coalition?" Or are those people going to be seeing the Democrats
as, you know, they're always against us. They're not even on
our Well, listen, they don't endorse mom and mom Donnie loses
by like a tiny bit. That's going to be a lot of people who share
similar beliefs like more of the like sock beliefs. They're going
to think, "Oh, this party will never support me. They'll always
come to the center. They'll always like corporate Democrats."
Okay, these people are going to go buy chank merch right away.
The corporate de Democrats and the
every time. They'll they'll clock out every time. Every goddamn
time. Okay. I think that's that's like your future now. I guess
it's just a matter of do you want to go which direction do you
want to go in? Might be like a moral direction. You figure out
what direction you want your party to go in and you commit. I
um I think this might be this might be the effect of having seen
how popular AOC was. Not AOC wasn't mayor, right? I think what
is she? Um House of Reps or Senator, I forgot. >> Uh House,
>> I think House of Reps. Yeah. Six
>> Um she is people look at her like she is what the Democratic
party is, even though she is just what the the populated cities
in the US is. She's not like Democrats across the the country
or anything. And yeah, the moderate Dems really do still exist
in a large way. She doesn't have all of the power that people
think uh has come into fruition for the socialist movement in
the Democratic party. It hasn't. But oh my goodness, the idea
that there's now going to be two like, okay, that just it kind
of makes sense. And those people will always be they'll always
have a bigger profile because they do represent to a small extent
like a big chunk of people who don't feel represented by the
Democrats. So they will always have more fans than like if you're
literally dead center in the Democratic party. Well, you're not
going to have more fans like obviously as the furthest left-leaning
members of the Democratic party. They're going to have everybody
who's further left of that will look at them as their representation,
right? And they're socialists in such a diluted sense of like
what that ideology means. >> Diet socialism. Yeah. >> Yeah.
They just they are here to support and advocate for your social
safety net >> basically. Yeah. >> They are basically
a check. They they want us to put a check on capitalism >> kind
of. Yeah.
>> All of the profits that these big companies get should
be going in the pockets of the Americans who need healthare,
who need affordable housing, etc. Y >> that is what they're
calling socialism and it's because people like AOC and Bernie
Sanders are willing to call themselves socialist.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um
I is it because they're willing to I think I think you could
do like the sock label and be fine
>> like the social democrat. >> Why do you even have
to? Why can't you just say that you're a Democrat and you just
want people to have healthcare? I've heard I've heard Hassan
say that >> decades of propaganda probably. But >> probably
that that would be my guess. Not on like a principal ground,
but just decades of propaganda. You're swimming uphill against
swimming up river, swimming upstream against. Yeah, >> you're
like working against the water, working against the current most
of the time. But
>> uh let's see. We're still >> I would say probably
that would be good, but is that better than
>> When does the fight happen?
Uh, I think we're supposed to go 15 minutes, but it's right here.
It's like right around. They're not even on our team. I I would
say probably that would be good, but is that better than what
IRI is suggesting that maybe in doing so, you alienate a lot
of the people that you might not see who are like, hey, I'm not
really sure about the uh uh, you know, this far left. Do you
think Kathy Hokll I understand that he's that he's I guess a
national figure or whatever in a way that um maybe Kathy Hogle
is a more more of a statewide figure or what have you, but like
if he stays on the fence, what's the good outcome if you're not
around with Tom Sisi? Tom Swis is going to do what he's going
to do no matter what, right? Tom Swisy isn't waiting for Hakee
to to run, right? Like and and Tom Swis Tomas do >> No,
no. What I'm saying is if you're fearful of the Tom Suis of the
world, if you're fear fearful for the Jared Goldens of the world,
they'll define themselves. They'll disassociate themselves. Um,
everyone, you know, in this day and age, candidates are free
to define themselves however they want. And so, it's really not
a big risk. >> They'll get in trouble. >> Who's going
to get >> They'll get in trouble if the leader of the Democrats
is associated with Manny when they're trying to represent the
Democrats in their district. And it's like, yeah, but your leader
is Mandani's best friend over here. >> So, I mean, was
that apply to AOC? I mean, you're just going to say it's because
she's an incumbent, but at the time in which she was making waves
and
>> this just like went to the future, I stole all of my
takes >> and it's like, yeah, but your leader is Manny's
best friend over here. >> So, I mean, was that apply to
AOC? I mean, you're just going to say it's because she's an incumbent,
but at the time in which she was making waves in 2018, should
they have endorsed AOC when she won the nomination? Of course
they should have because that was a Democratic candidate. Of
course he could you should have endorsed AOC at that time. But
>> that's for the House. That's different. >> But
but why is it different? Like why is it different to endorse
someone who who
>> is different is different. >> I get why he's saying
it's different. Um cuz they'll usually come out and speak for
uh like congressional seats and stuff like that. Those congressional
>> Yeah. But my goodness, I could have sworn they
or big ones like the governor of New York City like that impacts
the
>> Pretending like this is a small thing. There's a reason
why they're doing a lot of propaganda against him. They're really
worried. >> Yeah. Yeah. It's a I mean, it's a big deal.
I I I'm guessing that the economy of New York City is probably
bigger than a lot of countries.
>> Democratic social No. Oh god. Hold on. I got to back
it up so we can watch this. They should have cuz that was a Democratic
candidate. Of course, he could he should have endorsed AOC at
that time. But >> that's for the House. That's different.
>> But But why is it different? Like why is it different
to endorse someone who who
>> that reminded me that's Michael Jackson? Uh Michael
is it Michael Jackson in in South Park? That's ignorant. That's
different. That's ignorant. That's ignorant. Pisco, that's ignorant.
>> Democratic social >> national politics versus
city politics. Why is it different? Holy. I'm not comparing the
offices themselves, the nature of the contest. Yeah. It's not
about the nature of the office itself. It's about how visible
it is. And the Democratic candidate for mayor, this is like world
news and everyone's talking about it and he's going to be asked
every day about it and he's going to be dogged for it. He's going
to look weak.
>> I don't know. I'm having these >> Here. Here's
my issue. And I already told you I think my calculation changed
a little bit with um Adams dropping out. But I think there's
just like political uh reasons for Jeffrey's doing it. My problem
here, Pisco, quite frankly, is that I think a lot of Mum Donny's
most vocal supporters uh on >> Let's go.
I have a feeling I know who the most vocal supporter would be.
>> Mine and alternative media have intentionally made this
a divisive issue when it didn't need to be. First of all, this
standard never existed. >> Do you guys Are you guys ready
for Assan is bad? We're going to get some Assan is >> Okay,
I'm ready. A lot of it I think a lot of it >> made this
a divisive issue when it didn't need to be. First of all, this
standard never existed before like national democrats were never
expected to endorse mayoral candidates even for the biggest city
uh most popular city in the entire country. They invented this
standard and then started making this these demands. They're
not looking for unity. They're looking for, you know, the establishment
wing or the moderate wing to bend the knee to the new kind of
uh handsome popular progressive candidate. They intentionally
made this a divisive issue. They picked a fight over this. Don't
>> I totally disagree. No, I I I don't agree whatsoever.
I I think that, you know, regardless of how entrenched the standard
is for >> I don't know why IRI had to include that he thought
Manny was hot. That's an interesting approach. other politicians
to weigh in on a New York mayoral. It's happened before. It's
happened before. Uh Booker endorsed a previous mayoral election.
It's not unheard of for federal candidates for
state state or city. What would it take to be the standard? What
would it take should have been forced to endorse Eric Adams in
>> What do you mean by forced? What do you mean by forced?
Yeah, I think
Hang on. You don't actually believe >> No, no, no. I I
think that AOC should >> I think here's the here's the
actual difference to me. Okay. I think you endorse and you demand
an endorsement because the guy who came in second in our primary
just decided to run independent in the mayoral race, too. That
guy and I'm endorsing the actual candidate who won because that's
garbage. to be a Democratic politician for as long as Andrew
Cuomo's been to over the party. He loses a democratic process
to win the nomination and then he decides he's going to run anyway.
Nah. Nah. That's not how this works, bro. That's not how this
works. Head back to Little Italy, bro. Take a break. Okay, you're
done with politics. >> Endorsed uh Mayor Adams in when
he was running against the Republican. Yes, I do. What do you
mean I don't? Why? Why are you telling me I don't believe that?
I thought all these lefties Wait, no. It's it is not at Why should
she be forced to throw her? >> What do you mean be forced
to? So So when So when you say Hutch Hutch, when you say when
you say be forced, what do you mean by that? >> You're
saying you mean like I force her physically. What do you mean
by that? >> No, you you're saying >> why should she?
>> Wait, what the Pisco? Pisco heard from somebody. You
got to get more You got to get more analogies in your political
work, Pisco. And he just threw one in in the weirdest way I've
ever seen. What do you mean by force? Like forcer Oh, wait. Talk
about AOC. Hold on. You're saying like I force her physically?
What do you mean by that? >> I physically I Sorry, this
was I forgot what they were talking about. Should should AFC
be forced to endorse Eric Adams in 2021?
>> I I lost that context and I just got I I came back into
Pisco. Just saying that alone threw me off. Okay. >> You
You're saying that >> Why should she Hold on. I'm answering
your your question. Yeah. You're saying this should be the standard.
Therefore, she would be forced to act in accordance with a standard.
Correct. I >> I think that Democratic uh officials from
New York, whether they're federal representatives or not, should
endorse the Democratic um candidate for mayor. I do think that
that is a standard that should happen. That it should happen.
I am saying that. And and your response is there's not been like
universal uptake of that standard in the past. That doesn't mean
that it's wrong. >> Well, you understand the consequences
of this, right? Because if you're going to apply that standard
in New York, you got to apply that standard in all 50 states.
And now you're saying that more uh progressive House representatives
should be forced to endorse like conservative mayoral candidates
in you know whatever race in California or what >> wait
are there are there a lot of conservative mayoral candidates?
my understanding. So for anywhere where this would matter, it
would have to be a big enough city for you to like for it to
actually get attention, for it to actually get to be something
important, right? And and that there's like what 10, 15, 20 cities
like that in America? What do you And do any of those cities
have conservativeleaning
elections at all? Like I think Eric Adams is sort of infamous
for being the most conservative person that had won the or one
of the more conservative people that had won the New York mayoral
race. whatever tax. We are talking about the New York leader
of the Democrats, that is Hakeem Jeff, who is a representative
of the state of New York. He's one of the reps for New York.
And we're talking about Chuck Schumer, the leader of the Democrats,
who is the senator from the great state of New York. We're talking
about New York-based politicians. And not only them, they're
leaders of their respective congressional branch. So, they're
they are national leaders and they're being standard only applied
to New York. Why would it not be applied in every state? >> New
York is the New York is the center of the world. New York. It's
the Yeah, obviously. Hold on. It's because Hakee Jeff for one
is like elected in that place. It's like there there is some
bleedth through, right, of
there's some there's absolutely bleed through of like you're
a New York you're a house representative from the state of New
York. You have bleed through with the New York City mayoral race.
Obviously, like very obviously
>> So, so Hutch Hutch is like blowing this up and making
it about the entire country. It's like why the would you expect
AOC to endorse somebody in Texas? That doesn't make any sense.
She probably only cares about things that are close to her district
or close to her city or close to her state. That's where she
would get involved because it actually is on the minds of her
constituents. It would all be driven by what her constituents
are thinking about, right? That's what should be on your mind
as a politician. What do my constituents want? What are they
thinking about? I'm going to try to make them happy. >> I
would actually I would actually say she didn't like we're talking
about AOC still, right? >> Yeah. She didn't play to like
a a broad political movement or anything like that. Like in 2021,
she gave her endorsement during the primaries for someone that
she felt was like to her politics that her supporters would also
agree with. So the people who look to me, this is somebody like
me. >> That person did not win the primary. I don't think
she went on to endorse anyone after that. >> It would almost
appear dishonest if you did. Right. But she did go on to
um >> endorse Biden,
>> Biden. No, like I I think she still said Democrats need
to win over >> Republicans for the mayoral race, right?
>> Oh, I thought you were talking about federal. My bad.
I thought you were talking about the the presidential race. >> I'm
talking about her when it came to the mayoral race in New York
City in 2021. She had somebody she endorsed for the primary.
That person didn't win the Dem primary.
>> Um she didn't go on to officially endorse anyone else.
>> Okay. And that's what I thought it would be is like
if you've endorsed somebody in the primary and you don't want
to give out another endorsement, you just say I would vote for
the Democratic >> This one is your consistent one. And
that's what she did here. She endorsed Mum Donnie for the primary.
That's why she carries through and has an endorsement for like
the mayor cuz he made it. >> Yep. Yeah. >> So there
they are national leaders and they're being only applied to New
York. Why would it not be applied in every >> New York
is the New York is the center of the world.
Give me the [__]
>> No, I think I think you should probably do stuff in
California, too. California just doesn't have like super hotly
I can't remember a hotly contested thing in California. I think
it would apply to California, too.
>> A lot of people liked California when it was um what
is his name? Arnold Schwarzenegger or whatever when he was the
he was the mayor of Cal or governor. >> Yeah, he was the
governor of California. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> I heard
about that then.
>> Sure. I just meant like in terms of uh local race. I've
never heard about it. >> Okay. Okay. Give me a [__]
break. Hutch.
So this is this is what Hutch is saying. This is what Hutch thinks
I'm saying. Hutch thinks that the standard that I'm imposing
is I want the
>> I Yeah, I heard it. I heard it and I did a little twitch.
>> I know I don't know what his last name is. That's my
bad. >> Hakee Jeff on every single first selectman race
in the entire country. Do you think I'm that stupid that I'm
calling for the leader of the No. No. I just So, so then why
are you saying then it has to be the same for every state that
Jeff has to comment on every California for example? You're saying
that California representatives should weigh in on mayoral concept
coales
weigh in on Wyoming. Mayor >> only p if only Pisco if only
I could communicate with him through space and time. Okay. I
would just say obviously the difference is you have somebody
who lost the primary as a Democrat challenging the Democratic
nominee. That's bad. That's bad for business. That looks like
every single conspiracy you guys have ever been worried about
with regards to Bernie Sanders getting screwed. You're about
to replay that in New York City, right? Because oh well actually
the progressive candidate won this time. And what happened? Oh
well actually I sat out. I didn't I didn't nominate anybody and
the guy that that progressive candidate beat ran in the race
independent and ended up making a race of it and let's say he
loses. It's like oh yeah you just lost that whole co those that
coalition is going to say you >> also run it back a little
bit because I feel like Pisco said the thing like nope this isn't
like everything else. New York City is like the center of the
>> and yes the it is and Hutch just went no no no but what
I mean so so someone in California has to care about what's going
on in Wyoming? Oh, >> wait. Did he say I thought he said
California, but he said, >> but then he brought up Wyoming.
I'm supposed to be worried about the mayor in Wyoming.
>> that he said something every single
first selectman race in the entire country. Do you think I'm
that stupid that I'm calling for the leader of the No. No. I
just So, so then why are you saying then it has to be the same
for every state that Hakee Jeff has to comment on every mayoral
in California for example, you're saying that California representatives
should weigh in on mayoral contest
on the LA
weigh in on Wyoming mayoral races? Why would it? >> No,
he's saying there's something unique about New York City, right?
He is saying >> you didn't rewind back far enough to say
that New York City was like the center of the world. >> No,
I but I Yeah, I caught that part. I just didn't catch what Hutch
said. I think it's weird to say it's like the center of the world.
I think you could just listen if you have overlap with your constituents.
If your constituents are in the biggest city in Wyoming and you're
like the the senator for Wyoming, you could weigh in on that.
Maybe you should weigh in on that. If you have a Democratic candidate
and they can use your endorsement, you should probably be supporting
your party, right? >> I'm thinking it of the way that wired
rope is thinking right here. Wall Street. You do have other countries
that have investments in New York City. China does own a a string
of buildings in New York City. A lot of countries will own real
estate in New York City. They are
>> in that city in a way that >> they aren't invested
in other states, other cities in this country. >> Yeah,
sure. >> That is a hub to the world. is the New York City
mayor is considered like a stepping stone. Like many a person
has become mayor of New York City and then run in the Democratic
uh the the nomination for president, right? They've all flamed
out horribly. They've all looked but many of them have. >> They
all end up very powerful, very influential. That's what I'm saying.
>> Rudy went Republican. But yes, like many people have
run in one of the Democratic primaries. Yeah. like whether whether
you want to look at the aspirations of their uh political career,
you have the position of mayor of New York City, you're building
rapport with a lot of cities, a lot of countries, a lot of >> you
have a huge political network behind you. Yes. >> This
is someone who is going to be a power force in the Democratic
party whether you endorse him or not. And well, the funny thing
is is I think that's the other angle they're looking at it from
is that I think they don't want and the leftists kind of have
it right. They don't want you guys to have political connections.
They don't want the people supporting him to have political connections
to gain additional influence to gain additional influence over
their party and they like want to cut it off here and it's like
not democratic. It's not how that's precisely why this whole
time nobody's pointed out how up it is or very few people have
been pointing out how up it is that Andrew Cuomo lost and is
deciding to run as an independent. And yeah, again, I'll just
I'll just restate that to me that is 100% why you now go and
you endorse the candidate because somebody who they're literally
this person is literally acting against the will of your party.
They are not a good they're not somebody who cares about the
Democrats. They've they've shown that by working against the
will of the Democratic populace in that city. I think I think
Yeah. [__] Andrew Cuomo. Absolute loser. Should get
the out of here.
>> Oh Jesus. Hutch is uh Hutch is going crazy. Hutch is
Hutch is crazy. Look at these eyes. Jesus.
>> Should weigh in on Wyoming mayoral races. Why would
it only apply to New >> So So I I think that there is a
New York exceptionalism in general. I think that New York this
mayoral race is national news across the country. Yes or no?
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Yes or no? Yes or no?
>> Uhoh. Hutch. Hutch is in trouble. Hutch just woke the
beast. >> Oh no. Wait wait wait.
Hutch. Hutch. Is is the New York mayoral race national news in
a way that the these other contests are not? >> Uh yeah.
Yes of course. Uh number two I would apply a standard to for
example the LA mayor race. If you have some back independent
who lost the primary and you have Californian people who's a
centrist corrupt person There you go. Yes. Who is in the pocket
and is supporting and being the lawyer for BB Netanyahu at a
time when that's not where the base is at. If that happened in
LA, yes, I would expect the California delegation to support
the Democratic candidate. I don't think that's an absurd standard.
>> No. Now you're appealing to like uh you're appealing
to extraordinary circumstances when a moment ago you were saying
it's because they're New York Democrats. They should weigh on
weigh in on this mayor's race. No, I'm addressing youirectly.
don't understand how this standard wouldn't be applied across
the board all over the country. >> I'm now Pisco I'll give
Hutch a little bit here and say I think Pisco was sort of arguing
for a broader standard and now he's going to like this specific
scenario and saying it's important for the scenario. Right. I
do think he was talking about a standard before. >> I think
it makes sense though. >> It just wasn't clear language,
but he was talking about a standard and I think maybe the standard,
you know, as Hutch described it, they've sort of eliminated it.
That's not what Pisco meant. So they can walk away from it. But
it did seem like Pisco is going that direction >> It does
make sense to me. New York City is exceptional.
And if you do believe that the Democrats have a responsibility
to put their force behind the Democratic uh candidate for mayor
in that city, you're first you're starting with the Democrats
who already have a seat in office in the state. That's not to
say that the rest of the nation that nobody You would just say
first and foremost to set the domino forward. Why are the Democrats
who have a seat in the state of New York who have influence who
do know the voter base? Why are they not speaking to their voter
base? Who has their trust already had their vote? Why are they
not directing their votes >> Yeah, I think that's like
fair. >> Perfectly valid. >> But Pisco is falling
back from that >> I agree with you. >> Oh, he's falling
back from that. is the one who's saying, "No, no, no. I don't
expect people in Wyoming to do that." Right? Like, like I think,
or maybe you're saying, >> "No, he's saying that there's
no city like New York City in Wyoming." No, he's not going to
expect that. Like, there's a city like that in California, like
LA. I do expect that. >> Okay. Yeah. No, that's fair. Chicago,
LA, New York. I'm sure there's like one or two other cities I'm
not thinking of that could be like this as well. >> You
might you might be able to argue San Francisco could be kind
of like this, too. I think San Francisco is kind of close given
the tech sector. Maybe not anymore. I think SF was pretty up
there for you. Let me finish my thought. You shouldn't have a
standard that would force uh candidates to risk their own reputation
to be forced to endorse someone that they don't align with. That
would apply to AOC retroactively to Eric Adams in 2021. And as
as much as you say right now, yes, I would
>> I don't know. I I also don't know. Hutch is saying something
here. Does he like not align at all with Zoron? I would imagine
if he's a New York House candidate, he probably overlaps a decent
amount with Zoron, right? >> Did this get a labbotomy recently?
This is the same This is the same that I had a problem with cuz
he's running around. I'm going to take this on my team cuz they
blue no matter who. It's blue no matter who. Are you blue no
matter who? I'm not talking to you cuz you're not blue no matter
who. This is the only blue on the ticket. What's your problem?
>> True. Hold on. I think something recently hit Hutch
in the in the in the egg. Okay, hold on. What is this? What is
this? I thought it was going to be louder than that. It didn't
It didn't get I didn't know that we would get We're like, what?
It's just one month. Two months. Two months happened. Now Pisco
has to convince Hutch to be blue no matter who. >> Listen,
Hutch, shouldn't we support the Democratic candidate >> Eric
Adams in 2021? And as as much as you say right now, yes, I would
apply to that, I don't think that you actually >> would
apply. So I don't want to hear any from you. Therefore, when
Democrats in the future choose not or leftwing people choose
not to endorse a Democratic candidate for president. >> Oh,
Pisco is saying the same. Uhoh.
>> Stop it. >> I don't know how you I don't know
how you pre-watched this. We were We were doing the stream.
>> We were doing the stream. How did you watch it? >> I'm
going to find ways to hate on him. >> Okay. Well, you sure
as
like and the reason is
irony. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. So, you say it's the height
of irony. Should we condemn mom Donnie for not endorsing Kla
Harris? Of course. Correct. Yes or no? Yes or no? >> I
don't think so. >> So, we don't condemn. So, you don't
have any smoke. So, you don't have any So, I want to hear you.
You don't have any smoke for Hassan for not directly endorsing
Kla Harris. That's right. >> Hassan Per, he has way more.
just said, >> "Oh my god, he's actually he's actually just
making him eat his own [__] right >> Uh yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Uh it's good. It's >> You love to see it.
>> It's just a moral choice. You don't have to You don't
have to endorse somebody who doesn't represent your beliefs.
Why would you do that? Why would you tie a reputation to somebody?
Uhhuh.
Oh, okay. I see. I see.
Listen, Hassan [__] has way more effect over the
voters in any given loc. Apparently, where was Hassan supposed
to sway people? In LA,
you think Hassan's got a lot of Texas voters in his audience?
Seems unlikely. Anyway, um,
[__] me. Okay, whatever. Hassan's got a lot more
influence apparently, though. He more influence than the House
minority leader.
That's that is probably true, but I don't know if that means
you should not endorse the candidate or you should endorse a
candidate by his argument. >> How long >> that cuts
against your beliefs? >> How long until Pisco says, "Hutch,
you're my boy."
I think he's actually mad. I think he's actually mad and I don't
think he's going to do it at least for 5 minutes. >> I
I hope he says you're not my boy right now. Put him down.
Put him down. >> It's over. and boy status lost.
Shots than Christine Gnome though, please. >> We don't
condemn. So you don't have any smoke. So you don't have any So
I want to hear you. You don't have any smoke for Hassan for not
directly endorsing Kla Harris. That's right. >> Oh, this
is weird. Stephen Jillian, unpopular opinion. Pisco debates and
all I hear is how Destiny speaks. Pisco has always had his own
unique cadence >> that like I think comes from like his
his like mock trial stuff in law school or something. He's always
spoken in this exact way. Yes or no? Does this how this thing
will go? like yeah he's always done this exact like this way
of arguing and speaking in general is something I'm almost positive
he got taught like through law school or he took like >> uh
there there must be like classes you can take in law school for
the sake of like public speaking or something >> I don't
see him get like um emotional or I write he gets to anger and
like
>> yeah he he might even get like more mechanical when
he's more angry he'll do like this I I see him you guys can't
see it I'm doing the finger the the forward finger thing he puts
his his hand out. >> And then he does he he moves his hands
>> He's got like a Rob Diero. >> Rob mob boss going
on. Yeah. >> You know what you're talking about? >> Hassan
Per. He has way more. >> You just said you just said you
just said you don't
Donnie. >> Hutch. You just said you don't condemn mom Donnie
for not endorsing Kla Harris. I do condemn. Hang on. Hang on.
Let's
>> Let's get
a presidential race. >> Let's just be very clear. Hutch.
Hutch, let's be let's be very clear. You just said there should
be a difference. >> We're going to we're going to have
clarity. Hutch. Hut. Hutch. We're going to have clarity. Don't
worry. We'll get to everything. >> Do you think there should
be a >> Uh Hutch is trying to obiscate right now. He's
trying Pisco's got him like held. You know what's the what is
it called in like wrestling or UFC? It's like advantage. Pisco
has him in like the the hold on the ground right now and Hutch
is desperately trying to get away like no no no no no. He's just
like saying anything he can to stop Pisco from talking. standard
for a mayoral race and a presidential race. >> It depends.
It depends. It depends. So, but I'm asking you I'm asking No,
it's obviously different. Different contest, but in terms of
who to who to nominate, I asked you a question. Do you condemn
Donnie for not endorsing Kla Harris? Yes or no? >> I don't
care. He was >> Are you saying Are you saying you're Wait,
wait, wait. Are you saying you're indifferent? Yes or no? What
are you >> Yes. I'm >> So, are you are you indifferent
to Hassan not endorsing Kla Harris? >> No, because it's
different. That guy has Okay. So, way more influence
New York City assembly member.
>> Hassan has more influence than Hakee
>> Uh, so you could say outside of New York >> You
cannot. Hakee Jeff could put out a statement and have it covered
by every news outlet. He could put out a statement and have it
covered by Hassan.
>> So, let's say Okay, I see what you're I see what you're
saying. He could as minority leader obviously demand a lot more.
He would have a lot more traction with actual voters. Hassan's
got like if Hassan needed to get more likes on Twitter. Hassan's
got that. But from voters who would watch this. >> Half
of Twitter is Russia. So throw that out there. Exactly. Yeah.
Yeah. But maybe Hassan maybe Hutch is there with you. No, no,
no. Hassan has huge numbers on Twitter actually. >> He
is massive numbers on Twitter. That's a great point, Hutch. Thank
you, Hutch. That's a fantastic point, Hutch. Hassan is Hassan
is an influencer. How does he not have more influence? Guys,
are you guys out of your minds? >> Touch, you have rabies
in the brain. >> I'm not doing more of those right now
cuz we have to get back to this. Also, guys, I have not been
paying attention. We're way down at the bottom of the I have
not shilled a single time, guys. Sub, donate. We need to get
to 60 bucks. That's pretty easy for That should be two hours.
That would be two hours on the stream. I don't know why I put
one in there. It's 60 for two. So, two more hours on the stream.
We need about 10 subs to get there. Okay, about 10 subs. You
guys can do it. Donate subs, donate kicks, donate through Streamlabs
or Kickbot. I'm not going to keep showing because we're in the
middle of an army. >> Not endorsing Kla Harris. >> No,
because it's different. That guy has >> Okay. So,
more influence
city assembly member. >> So, now the level of influence
matters, right? So, now you're you're okay. So, >> oh,
this was this one right here is over assembly member. That's
>> basically suggesting you're basically suggesting that
influence and how notable the race is is affecting your calculus
about whether or not you think an endorsement should or should
not >> race. This is so silly, dude. We were we were on
the same page like weeks ago that it was the right thing to endorse
Manny. Now you've reversed your position. I don't know what your
position is. >> No, no, no, no. I'm just pushing back against
the the the
constant rhetoric that I'm hearing from Mani's most vocal supporters.
To be clear, they picked a fight over this issue. They purposefully
made it divisive. It's >> Why is this is this vocal supporter
like Voldemort? Why can't we say that >> they did this
to me? obvious the standard the standard is consistent. The standard
is you not you support you endorse a Democrat unless there are
exceptional circumstances like some he's a child
>> uh subbox society thank you for the five gifted let's
go five more guys and we got two more hours of the stream on
vocal supporters sent Ethan Klein skulls some [__]
and he's a child
no
it's you who's provided that provisor though it's you who's saying
it's only exceptional to the president. I think that it should
be more broad than that. I think the Democrats should more >> You
have to localize it. So like New York State Dems or New York
City Dems like at the state level of government. That's the pressure
is more on them to get behind like candidates like that. You're
talking about national Democrats who have their own constituents
and their own reputations to consider. Wait, >> you're
talking about a Twitch streamer, >> but also does Hutchnot
realize that Jeffre is also a he's a state represent? I don't
know. He's like saying state Democrats. I Is it just because
he's >> considering he's considering him national cuz it's
for Congress, right? But he is a He represents the state. He
got voted in by the state. >> I see. I see. Like he's saying
state senators, not state. >> He's looking for a way to
differentiate >> Yeah, I got it. I got it. I got it. >> With
his last two brain cells. Yeah. >> Yeah. And you're saying
that they should be forced to by some.
Do you remember this argument, Hutch? Do you remember this argument?
The argument was the lesser of two evils. Why would you endorse
the lesser of two evils? Hm. Maybe because it's less evil. So
if you have a principal position against M Donnie because you
think his policies are you can just say that. You can say, "Listen,
I don't agree with M Donnie, but I'm not going to support a Republican."
Guess what? All the Republicans do that. All of the Republican
elected officials do that. Do you think any of them sit on the
fence like this? They don't do that. They support their own candidates,
but we can't bring ourselves to do that. And it's And it was
wrong with mom Donnie did it and it's wrong with No, no, no.
Come on. Come on. How many How many Hold on. How many How many
congressional Republicans have endorsed Leewa in this >> I
don't [__] I don't
You just said
>> Are the Is the Republican candidate winning? Hold on,
hold on, hold on. Maybe maybe the Republican candidate gets a
votes that I'm unaware of and like it would matter what the Republican
nomination or endorsement was. Oh no, it doesn't matter at all.
This Curtis Leewa guy got 27% of the vote in the last presidential
election 2021. He's not getting anywhere near winning. There's
no point in Republicans endorsing for the city because their
voices don't [__] matter. Oh, of course. You mean
to tell me that the dude and all the people who went around saying
blue no matter who we need to get rid of the leftist who won't
support our people. I would I would vote in a socialist. Will
you vote in a moderate?
Will you vote in a liberal? Oh no you won't because you call
it fascism. Yeah. That's why I'm only going to make coalitions
with blue no matter who. And then as soon as they have to eat
their words, here's a guy who's a socialist. It's like, uh, >> I
don't think it'll help, actually. >> I really don't think
it'll help. Would it even help if Jeffree said something? >> Why
do I have to say anything? >> I don't think it'll help.
>> Why do we have to scream blue no matter who? Can we
silently do this? >> We could be the silent majority. We
take it back. We'll be the silent majority. >> Lawler Lawler
has endorsed Lawler endorsa. Lawler endors Lua. >> And
you understand you understand the field. You understand the field
is fractured for the conservatives in this in this race. It's
fractured in a way that it shouldn't be for the Democrat. I see
Republicans did endorse Lou. Okay. New York [__]
city. This is not true. Republicans constantly weigh in on mayoral
races. This is not true. >> So Republicans fall in line
for each other. And if it were a clear don't do the standard
that you're talking about. >> My god.
>> Roy Moore. >> Yeah. No. Republicans fall in line
behind who Trump endorses. And that's that's who wins the primaries.
That's like how it goes. They absolutely do it.
Oh my god, Pisco is so shortsighted. Oh my god, Pisco is so shortsighted.
>> Is that a short joke, >> guys? Guys, Pisco is
so shortsighted. They don't understand that like Israel is about
to own the Tik Tok algorithm and they're going to start mass
censorship on all platforms and everyone's going to love Israel
again and we're all going to support Israel and then all of these
people who didn't support Israel, they're going to go in goologs.
That Pisco isn't taking the long view is what I just projected
onto that guy. There there is no standard that congressional
Republicans endorse mayoral candidates. This is not a thing.
>> So So you're narrow you're making it so narrow that
you think what I'm suggesting is that there's a uniform standard
for Republicans even to weigh in on other you know mayoral elections
across the country. And so you're saying there's no standard
because I haven't heard Republicans weigh in on mayoral elections.
So this is the this is this is New York City. So in general in
general the Republicans coalesce behind their candidate and I
think that's what should happen with Democrats in any kind of
major you know uh notable race the Democrats should back the
Democratic candidate. It's you you want to make a different standard
and say well sometimes no definitely when it's the president
but not but not if hang on definitely when it's the president
but not if you're a mayoral you know candidate in the future.
I'm not going to and look at your standard, right? Like I'm going
to say that you should endorse Kla Harris unless you're like
a New York uh assemblyman. Then you have no requirement to endorse
>> your assembly. Absurd. It's absurd. Of course, there
should be a uniform standard to support the Democratic >> All right,
we got to put Okay, so >> I don't want this
in the helicopter hat ever telling me calm down. >> I I
need the side by side. Do you look at that comment I just put
up on the stream or can you see it? >> What do I say? What
comment? >> Oh, it might not be there anymore. Okay, it's
uh Hutch and Hutch and Cash Mattel have the same eyes. >> They
absolutely do. Hutch and Cash Mattel are in a position they're
not ready for at all times. They're like a deer in the headlights
constantly. Amazing.
This is a question that maybe this will build a bridge. Maybe
this will start another fight. I'm just curious, Hutch. If there
was some mayoral race in Wyoming that was as big as the mom donny
thing that was making national headlines, do you think it would
be at least reasonable to expect heads of Democratic congressional
caucus?
Also, >> why would it ever? >> Oh, but like for whatever
reason, this is let's say um I have a good example. Let's say
the Georgia runoffs. The Georgia runoffs made like a huge they
were a massive deal because the Senate was deadlocked, right?
There could be a case like that where it's like, oh, we have
a not mayoral obviously, but like it's smaller state politics,
but it's like, oh, it actually has like stakes. That's what's
driving the New York City mayor race conversation is there's
massive stakes to who wins the New York mayor race.
>> Consequential. Another one might be if there was probably
because of immigration issues or maybe with um relations with
other countries like Venezuela right now. If there were if there
was enough power in the mayor position for Florida or Texas like
these
>> um I feel like those are very very important roles as
well. >> Yeah, sure. >> Important positions. There's
a lot of other countries that you get dual citizenship at like
in Florida. Like I know for Dominican Republic, people in DR
can vote for their own uh their own in Florida for some reason.
Like they have set up for their country in the state of Florida.
>> I think similar is set up with like Puerto Rico. I don't
know. But I I get what you mean. >> Yeah. I just think
I think like this is where all of the conversation is. I think
by virtue of this being a massive news story, that is why you
you expect the endorsements and stuff, you expect national eyes
on it is because it is the story of the Democratic party right
now. There's this >> and the shutdown and other than that
ain't got going on. >> Do you feel like you need to explain
an analogy why this should matter? But it should just be the
fact that we've been covering this. They have been covering this
for 3 weeks. It is national news. Other countries are getting
this on international news. >> Take even longer than three
weeks. >> Why do they even need to bring up what if this
was happening with Wyoming?
>> Yeah. Well, it's not. >> Why can't we engage with
the fact that it is a big deal? >> Why the do you know
a guy named Zora
>> Why do you even know that name? That name is absurd.
That name like there you would never know that person outside
of like something that's making national news or you know you
really like Sharma. Not sure which. is not to necessarily say
I fullthroatedly endorse momani but to say hey I support the
Democratic candidate in this race against a >> you would
have to make the situation analogous so like in this race why
are you laughing you would have to make the situation analogous
when it's convenient
let him finish let me finish my point you asked me a question
was that a rhetorical question or you
yes I want to make that clear in in this hypothetical if it is
uh sort of like an insurgent candidate that came up really big
with with the grassroots campaign and he was like a socialist
and he was like a clear favorite to win the race then no I don't
think that I would want that pressure there. >> You're
making a mom Donnie exclusive rule. You're special pleading for
mom Donniey's case. You were accus
You're saying it would have it would have to be like listen to
me. So, so this is the >> I recognize so many of the uh
the chatters I recognize so many of the chatters that are just
like it's like this is just sidescatters
in here that uh I know are just like they're from a certain community.
No, no, no, not Aquilla. Aquilla is not brain broken at all.
Aquilla is uh like a pisco fan. He Aquilla is like a like a shy
ashamed DJer. He's like still a DJer and he really hates anybody
who makes him feel self-conscious about it. That's that's his
own curse to bear. Okay, it sucks for him. I feel bad for him.
But he's not somebody who's like out there preaching the gospel
or something like that. A little little better. Okay, special
pleading. This is the special
>> He's not one of these like fringe people who have to
go and attack anybody who has different opinions. Okay, why he
likes Pisc This is the special pleading,
>> This is the special pleading. What Hutch is just saying
in response to soy pill I think is a very like on all fours example
hypothetical where it's a race in Wyoming and where you know
it's national news. He says it would have to be just like the
mom Donnie race and then I would apply the mom Donnie specific
standard which is just for mom Donnie your special special pleading
not >> Oh special. You just misspoke. >> I'm the
one who's consistent. Endorse the Democrat. That's my consistency.
Do you not understand the logic of like if the race is not very
close and the and this hypothetical Democrat in Wyoming was like
10 or 20 points up was like the clear favorite? >> Why
is the race not close? Hold on. Can Hutch explain why the race
isn't close? >> Why? Why does that matter? I'm sorry, sir.
You're a political influencer. You're a political commentator.
Why do you need to wait to know where the winds are going to
blow before you commentate? What is the point of you? I think
he's saying that like the if there are downsides to the endorsement,
which he's arguing there are, then if it if you don't need to
give that endorsement, if you don't need to like endorse the
person who's going to win by 30%, then don't do that cuz it's
just pragmatic, right? You're you're actually going against your
your like sort of principal position for pragmatism in a way
that like the other person could understandably say, "Okay, okay,
that's >> I disagree because I think that that's what you
would do if you were in support of populism.
If you just want to go with where the popular vote is going to
go, yeah, there's all the reason in the world to hedge your bets.
But if you are principally
Democrat, blue no matter who, you actually don't have justification
for saying this person shouldn't back the Democratic party, >> which
like all of these people are there. So I think IRI is a little
different in that he's like probably just do whatever is best
for like Democrats nationally. I don't think Hutch necessarily
has that opinion. I think that I think that that standard is
sort of going to be like fair weather only appearing right now
for this one specific thing. I don't think any of them would
ever say it's not blue no matter who, right? Cuz you it's just
like yeah, it's just it's
I can I can sort of understand part of what Hutch is saying,
but I again I don't think it's like legitimate. >> It does.
It's not legitimate to me because I know who he is before this
statement. It's legitimate to me from IRI's point of view because
I because I has always like um I don't think he's ever been a
rush to change or rush to uh progress or moving closer to the
left. He's always been electoral politics
incremental because if you go too far too fast, it's going to
swing in the swing back in the opposite direction. You don't
want unstable change. Yeah, >> that doesn't really work
with who Hutches as a content creator. >> It does not.
It does not. Sorry, I'm looking at also it's a funny Pisco picture
right now. Pisco Pisco about to end this guy's whole. Hold on
one second. There's uh Can I get this? >> Honestly, if
Pisco ends this saying, "Hutch, you're my boy." Pisco is gay.
>> He's going to do it 100%. >> That's made. Don't
give him a cool >> Cherry doesn't know. Cherry doesn't
know the meme. Too bad. There's like a million whole meme. It's
told. >> I don't get it. I never want to get it, >> That's
fine. >> Should we put some standard on like what's most
likely like a conservative Democrat serving in Wyoming to lend
their reputation
uh to a candidate that maybe they're totally ideologically different
from? I don't understand how
>> So, is the is the Democrat from Wyoming the like I'd
say this is built into you being the House minority leader is
you have to do this. you might have to take hits in some ways
that people aren't expecting. Like Hakeem Jeff is not losing.
You just make the statement in a way that it's like it's not
an endorsement of the politics. It's an endorsement of our candidate
who won the primary. Like this is a and a candidate we'd support.
You shouldn't if you wouldn't support the candidate as the leadership
of the party. There should be a system to say no, no, no, don't
let that person run with us. [__] that person. Right?
I don't think you should let somebody run in your primary and
then when you lose, when you don't get the the answer the rest
of the party wants, you go, "Oh, well, I'm going to work against
this person now." I don't think that's acceptable. That seems
totally unacceptable to me. the endorsement now is turning also
on the closeness of the race and so there's some special formula
you're calculating so everyone should just go to my calculation
changed earlier in the
plug into your computer so so when when it comes to the endorsement
question because it's relying on all these you know multiplicity
of factors including is it does it have the mandani specific
factors that we should consider the ideology specific factor
uh the jurisdictional specific factor and then your intuitions
about who's you know going to win or not then we'll ask Hutch
about you know what should we endorse or we could just go with
the universal more rule which is in general the Democratic leaders
should support the Democratic candidates. That seems a lot easier.
>> To to be clear, I guess the calculation is and the reason
Mamdani specific matters is would it hurt people in other districts
who would otherwise support Hakeem Jeff or want to support the
Democrats by endorsing someone that they wouldn't like them endorsing
like Mom Donnie more than it would help Mom Donnie win this race.
And if that's the case, then it would make sense not to endorse.
I don't know if that's the case, but clearly do you not see that
that's a possibility that >> I recognize look at how reasonable
I am. I recognize that's possible for some ultra-conservative
members, right? Some some very conservative Democrats who are
in tough thing. Am I going out here, you know, I I might grumble
grumble. Am I saying Jared Golden is a for not endorsing uh Montani?
No. I'm out here saying the leaders of the Democratic party in
safe states, right, in New York State, safe state for [__]
Schumer. Uh, I think Pisco is ignoring the fact that like the
the thing they're going to do is they're going to run an ad saying,
"Look, Hakeem Jeff, the leader of your party, supports
Are you really going to vote for
Doug Hicksville in like Wyoming? Are you going to vote for him
here? Given that Hakee Jeff, like the leader of the Democratic
Party, one of the Democratic Party leaders, is endorsing socialism,
right? That's that's what they're arguing. He's just not engaging
with what they're arguing." I think you could still ignore that.
You can still like just say I don't care. They're going to call
us. Listen, >> you don't. >> They call Biden a socialist.
What? It does. It literally That's It doesn't >> Dooby
Booby said it. Please have normal names, you guys. I can't shut
you out like this. They're going to do that anyway. And guess
what? We do it to the other side. I point out when Trump endorses
a I point out when he endorses a white nationalist.
Right? That's what the everybody does. And guess what? Whether
or not this dude is a socialist who is um I mean, they obviously
aren't anti-American,
you just need to know how to set your own set your own narrative
cuz they're going to give you a bad narrative no matter what.
They're going to do negative propaganda no matter what. >> I
will say though, Biden's not a socialist. Trump really didn't
endorse
>> That really happened. That did actually literally happen.
So >> we tend to not have to make up what Trump does. He
just actually does it. doesn't care how ridiculous it sounds.
We don't do the ridiculous thing, but for some reason are scared
of how it
>> Uh, yeah, obviously it is pathetic. Sorry, I got sent
this.
>> What's this? >> Why? Why is Hutchki making faces
like Sorry, I saw this on the other screen there for a sec. This
is God. Sorry. It's crazy. And Hakee Jeff, who has to appeal
to the conservatives and the leftwing, guess what? It goes both
ways. Yes, of course has responsibilities to members of his caucus
who are more conservative. He also has a responsibility to members
of his caucus who are leftwing. The problem is my intuition is
a lot of Democrats think it only goes one way. It only goes to
the right um and doesn't go to the left. And I think it's I was
calling out each and every person who didn't endorse Kla Harris
cuz I actually believed in harm reduction. But the notion that
we >> I think I think I remember you know how you ever
like look at your Twitter timeline and it's just Pisco replying
to a whole bunch of like senators and congressmen. You ever just
have a day where you see Pisco reply to every senator congressman?
Do you disal Trump doing you disavow >> I have seen that.
Yeah. >> Elected official >> I have seen that. Yeah.
>> If I was any other person sometimes I would think that
Pisco is a bot. >> He is. He's like a He's a Is it T-Max?
What the What the [__] are the Terminators? It's
the Terminator model name. It's moment's gone. We could have,
you know, a Republican or Cuomo or >> T1000. Yeah, T1000
>> before yesterday Adams >> except he's supposed
to figuratively in a video game. No, figuratively electorally
Republicans >> as mayor when we have a much better alternative
that sends shivers down my spine and it's wasting talent in Mount
Donnie. And I don't see why we can't just apply a simple rule.
a simple rule which is in these kind of big races when all the
attention is focused by the media we endorse a Democratic candidate
and if you want to make it a weaker statement and say I don't
support all his policies or we have many disagreements that's
what the Republicans do when they have their controversial candidates
but they step up and they endorse >> I don't see any reason
to endorse him like that first of all the goalposts are just
going to get moved like you said Pisco that you should have endorsed
him earlier you didn't endorse him hard enough so it doesn't
make any difference to me I could steal man your argument in
that Hakeem Jeff district is in New York City. So he shares constituents
with Mandani. So it makes sense to endorse. Fine. But he's not
just an average congressman. He's the leader of the Democrats
nationwide in the House of Representatives with a three seat
majority and control of the House goes through those Jared Golden
districts. So he has to make the calculation. Does it matter
if I endorse Mum Donnie? Is it going to make a difference in
his race? No. Does it help make my job easier or harder? And
again, is it not going to make any difference at all with Adam's
out? I would imagine it's going to make a difference with Adams
out, right? Or are they saying up until this point that maybe
they're arguing? Maybe they're just arguing up until this point
and now they'd expect Jeff to come out and do it. But IR already
said he doesn't think he's he should do it. So no, I don't know
why I is making that difference. >> And I feel he's made
the calculation. >> He's thinking about electoral politics.
He's thinking about Congress
>> being able to um to have favors on the table and stuff
like that. >> Yes. But he's sorry. He added the part where
he said, "But also the race isn't close." So I think that's like
referring to a different time when Adams was in. The race wouldn't
have been close. >> I think the race will be close. >> Given
that it's ranked choice especially, you can't you can't really
>> Yeah. So I think I think it will be close and I think
um >> or at least I can't know. >> Yeah. I think
IRI I he said that like it mattered. I don't think it doesn't
matter for his opinion. I don't know why he included that. >> Does
it help make my job easier or harder? And I feel he's made the
calculation.
Oh, the the DNC primary was ranked choice. Is the mayoral election
itself ran choice? >> It should also be ranked choice.
>> and it makes my job harder to win control of the House
of Representatives for the Democrats next year if I cozy up the
MD. That's what it comes down to in >> and the results
for this kind of spineless uh like looking at um I'm not saying
you're spineless. I'm saying I think the leaders are spineless
in that they're always looking at these opinion polls and over
complicating these things. And we smell it. The Democratic approval
ratings are at all. >> There is something to be said for,
okay, you can't miss, but at some point you have to dictate the
tone, right? You have to say, actually, this is the way the country
is going. I'm going to get ahead of the ball. I'm not just going
to go see where the ball is. I'm not going to constantly run
after this ball and never catch it. I'm going to see what the
direction the ball's going. I'm going to go forward. I'm going
to make a educated guess. I'm going to like try to actually make
a commitment to to something principally and have that pay off
for my party. And but but what I is saying is no, no, no. He
wants to be like the Disney of political parties, okay? With
all these IPs that nobody wants to watch anymore cuz they crowd
they crowdsource every element of them. >> Time lows. It's
because of this kind of where we're always looking at consensus
polls. We're always looking to try to manufacture the perfect
answer instead of just going with our gut and doing what's right.
Sometimes, of course, think with your head, but in this context,
what's the harm? How is Jared Golden going to be harmed because
we, you know, nominated the Democratic nominee in New York City?
Have you seen uh Mandani statewide polls or his nationwide polls?
By the way, >> I I'll tell you how he's going to be. >> They're
they're not good. They're not good because Jerry Golden Jared
Golden is part of the Democratic caucus and the leader of the
Democrats is Hakee Jeff. So, anything Hakeem Jeff does is going
to rub off on Jared Golden and his >> Well, then we're
because the brand is the brand is dog right now. And it's all
>> this Pisco guy. This Pisco guy is a smart cookie. >> Okay.
Yeah, the the mayor race, it's only the primary that they did
ranked. They're not doing ranked for the >> Yeah, I'm guessing
they've never done it cuz the general is usually just a Republican
candidate versus a Dem candidate and nobody ever really wins
independent. It's like and it really the the p the general mayoral
race is sort of a formality most of the time. I believe I think
it's basically like the Dem nominee just wins and like the the
general is probably just a formality. It's probably cost like
more money to tabulate or something for rank choice or some [__]
>> I don't think it costs more money
>> It goes through the same scantron >> Oh, they
have scanners. Okay, never
>> Okay. Well, maybe not then. I don't >> Unless
you write in, but that's the same with anything. >> Yeah,
I wouldn't know. I would know. >> It doesn't matter. >> If
it's all about winning, we should support the Democratic candidate.
If it's all about winning, that's what we should do. It >> It's
about controlling the House of Representatives next year. How
do you get it? How do you win it? And I think the strategy obviously
goes through these moderate districts and so does >> If
I was convinced that this would significantly affect the the
chances of the Democratic House, this non-endorsement, I would
be like, fine. I'm not convinced by that. I don't think there's
a good case for it. And I think it makes you look weak in front
of your base. And the base hates the leadership. And it's because
of decisions like this. And it's because of silent decisions
like in the past when we didn't use our leverage in the the other
negotiation. It's this kind of running scared instead of being
a leader. Running scared and and being like sort of pushed around
by your fears. This is the kind of that turns off the base and
the base is so disanimated by this kind of fecklessness in my
opinion. I love you guys. I love Hutch. Hutch is my boy. Hutch
is my boy.
>> you know, you know, >> this is exactly why Dems
lose. They pretend like they're about anything.
They're they pretend
anything
really gets them at their core, at their principles at the end
of the day. They just wanted to yell for like a couple days,
couple hours, and then they're
>> This uh this Pisco guy is not consistent. Okay, >> Pisco
doesn't care about anything. Don't believe him. >> You
can't scream at this guy about how wrong he is for I don't know,
it's like 10 minutes. Actually, this probably doesn't mean anything,
but I'm I'm just laughing, okay? Because every time he goes hard
on Hutch, he has to like back off and do Hutch, you're my boy.
Okay, you're you're my boy. >> I I get heated because look
at Pisco laughing. He's trolling. He's not trolling. Or you think
he's trolling and saying you're my boy. >> How is this
your boy? This Hutch is the reason that Mani might lose the election.
How's that your boy? >> He's my boy. Hutch is my boy. Hutch.
>> I thought you guys cared about democracy. Clearly not.
>> I been so leadership and and it's taken so long and
they're going to have to keep fielding this question. And you
look weak as when you don't answer it. >> I I don't understand
like I I I feel you keep calling it weak weakness and spinelessness
and to me it's just a like it's just a political calculation.
It's not about fear or anything like that and and you talk about
the base being upset. Do you really think that Mandani represents
the base of the Democratic >> I'm not represents a growing
movement on the left of disaffectiveness with the Democrats not
pushing back, not fighting back and finally someone coming out
and doing a little more populist thing. And that's why he has
this national support and energy. And by saying, "I will not
endorse." Pisco is saying, "Well, you're kind of saying, well,
oh, if you want, didn't Hutch get into politics because of Bernie
Sanders?" Isn't that what got Hutch into politics? >> No
way. Is that what it was? >> I'm almost positive that Hutch
got into politics because he wanted to go see uh Jesus because
he wanted to what do you call it? He wanted to
support Bernie Sanders. I thought that I'm pretty sure that's
what got him into politics. So, it's just kind of crazy that
he's like, "Why would you ever support this guy? Why would you
ever want It's like, yeah, it's the exact same thing that made
you want to support Bernie. The thing that got you into politics,
the thing that got you this animated, that's what you're looking
for. You're looking to get that energy back. Come on, man.
Please, please, for the love of God,
>> Change. This is just like the David Hog thing. If you're
trying to come in and and primary people and be progressive,
we don't want that." and it kind of builds into this like establishment
like hard hard rock that's not going to move thing. So, I understand
at the very least I think it's silly that he wouldn't just say,
"Hey, you know, I don't agree with everything this guy does,
but it's great that we have this guy and this energy and I I
think it's great that people are voting for him and I support
this movement and I support him over the Republicans." But he
won't even say that. It does come off as a little bit like, "Come
on, give us something even if it's not going to be like the the
deep." >> And then the Mayor Adams statement, Hutch, and
then the Mayor Adams statement. I told you I didn't. >> I
know. I know. It's all part of the I weigh that in because I
see that he didn't call on him to resign at a time when he is
he's literally cooperating with Tom Hman and Trump and it's all
part of the same. I'm like who side are you on? I mean, I just
I just feel like you guys are not really reckoning with the point
that IRI has made, I think, like four times now, which is like
the House Speaker has a totally different set of considerations
to uh ponder when you when considering something like that. Like
a political endorsement is a big deal. Like an official formal
political endorsement, you are lending your name and your
>> Uh everybody knows that. Don't counter points right
now. Don't explain something that everybody understands, everybody
agrees with. Don't just say some [__] that is totally
worthless in moving the conversation forward. Please, for the
Why do people do this? I just want you to know that like I'm
just going to at some point when somebody does this, I'm going
to like mock them and explain that they're like they're basically
just showing me they can recite a times table, like a multiplication
table. It's like that's the level of contribution you're doing.
You're just reciting a multiplication table during our argument.
You're saying things that nobody disagrees with that like we
all understand and it's just you taking up oxygen.
Shut the up
to a candidate. And so it's not some small gesture. And uh I
don't uh like Mum Donnie, you know, I looked at his platform.
I liked like 90% of a his platform. Didn't like like 10% of it.
I thought uh he ran a brilliant campaign and I would be happy
to vote for him if I lived in New York City. But there are going
to be representatives that serve in districts that are a little
freaked out at the idea of endorsing a guy. Hey, Pisco needs
to come back with guess what, Hutch. Guess what, Hutch? Uh, they're
going to run a [__] they're going to run the same
ad, but instead of saying Hakeem Jeff endorsed, they're going
to say Hakeem Jeff stayed silent because he because he actually
secretly supports communism. And it's going to do the exact same
thing it would have done anyway, except you're letting your party
get used for some federal some national, you know, combat by
with with Andrew Cuomo and and like corporate Democrats trying
to maintain control of your party. You're going to let that happen.
You're not going to support the Democratic candidate. You're
just going to totally check the out and h Yeah. Sorry. Do you
>> I'm trying >> We're like trying I'm trying to
order food right now. Sorry. I'm uh I just lost my I lost my
train of thought cuz I have not eaten anything. Okay, I need
some food.
>> Okay. Okay, I'm done. >> Okay, cool. All right,
one second.
There we go. Thank you. Okay,
>> so much pressure having to make a decision what you
want to eat.
>> Who said that the end goal is to seize the means of
production? You know what I mean? Like he's just like not even
a democratic socialist. He's like a socialist socialist, right?
Like that's going to freak a lot of people out. And I think you're
underestimating
the that kind of um endorsement backfiring. I think you're under
underestimating the risk of that happening. Like we saw it in
20 we saw it in 2020 like the 2020 was like a really important
cycle because we won a trifecta but we lost seats in the house.
And one of the reasons why we lost seats in the house is that
there was a perception about Democrats that we like wanted to
like you know get rid of police and uh become like super radical
in that way and it cost us house seats. I I can understand where
Pisco is coming from. You feel
>> Okay. But like I understand that was the perception.
Some of your Congress people leaned into that perception in a
way that was like stupid >> cuz they're they look at social
media and they were like the people want the police defunded
and I'm going to do what the people want. Like get unelected.
Okay. That's a 12year-old. That's a 12-year-old Bosch viewer
telling you defund the police. >> Yeah. Uh, with with this
one, it's like Mamani seems like a good a good candidate, like
a very good candidate. And I don't know. I don't know, man. I
It seems like such a goofy thing to compare that like, oh, people
like not calling out rioting, breaking the law versus I'm going
to endorse this guy who ran a great campaign who I just who I
just said I loved. I loved as a politician. I would totally vote
for him if I was in New York City. And it's like that's the same
as Democrats not sufficiently
uh condemning violence in the BLM riots. the Yeah, but the problem
>> they wait until times like this where they feel like
it doesn't really matter to them. Like, oh, that's just the New
York City mayoral race. When it was Kamla getting pressed for
some of the things that she said over the BLM, they had no issues
with it. No issues. It was blue no matter who. Don't ask questions.
I'm not going to give answers. I'm not conceding a inch to the
people to the moderates who are asking anything. I'm not conceding
an inch to the progressive leftist who want more who want her
to support trans people. She's just saying silent like you did
not want to hear now like then but now you're now you're the
skeptic and you don't want to have to
push in any direction or make any claim to like what you want
to support or >> when like I honestly I'm just going to
be real about what I think. I think I think if Mum Donnie didn't
have a picture of him eating and hanging out with Hassan,
no problem. I I actually think that's like the primary thing
that's holding Hutch's brain up here. >> I think if if
mom Donnie wins, Hutch will be the first person sucking him >> Well,
he already talked about how that's not even really a prediction.
>> This is why I wanted another AOC. I loved Bernie. This
is who Yeah, everyone should get behind this guy. He's really
saying what what's motivating the voter base right now. >> Wow.
He's speaking to the people. >> He'll be the first one.
>> Guys, have you heard about this Gaza thing? It's kind
of bad.
>> There's like people dying. >> No, no, no, no.
He knows what's happening in Gaza. He's a Contra. He's a Contra
type. >> Yeah, I think he I think he is actually informed
to some extent. I But yeah, it's the the Contra points thing.
You're right. You're right. You're right. >> Feels like
the Democrats are missing out on the energy and the excitement
and and why people like Mom Donnie. I get it. And u but I really
question Mom Donniey's national appeal as well. Well, I haven't
really seen any evidence to >> like at least IRI has the
excuse of being the perpetual
democratic wet blanket that he's like, "No establishment. No
establishment. No establishment every single time." Like, at least
that's his like basic position all the time on everything. He's
just like, "Yeah, what what are what is what is Nancy Pelosi
saying?" Yeah, Nancy's right. Ny's right. >> It has to
be somewhat depressing for him because he is a progressive, he
would >> Oh, maybe. Uh, but I think I think he's uh pro-
Israel. I don't know what that means for the his democratic positions.
It's just he's doomer from watching electoral politics all day
every day. >> Yeah. And well, and I think he he sees himself
as like uh I almost feel like he's become a bit of a caricature
as well, right? That he's like, I'm going to he basically is
like whatever the Dems say, that's my position, and then I'm
going to backwards reason and make sure I can support it. Because
the few times that we've watched like let's say an interview
in Congress or testimony happening in front of Congress that
is a
>> I would lose hope watching them do that partisan every
individual is just there for their clippable moment. Yeah. I
don't know how he stays in the game. >> I don't know. I
assume it's cuz of his job. I assume like he's building up. He's
grinding up a viewership. I I assume it's because it's his job.
>> Yeah. He knows more than anybody about what's going
on there >> about like the dayto-day of Congress. Yeah,
he does a lot. It was a lot for >> I would drink if I watch
that stuff >> up that I understand he's on national TV
and people do like him around the country, but is he really resonating
with Democrats around the country? I'm not so sure. Have you
seen evidence? >> Whoever answers polls is the opposite
IRI. They actually he's not as popular national uh as as he is
in New York. So, >> well, there's a lot of there's a lot
of like undecideds with him. He's unknown and so there's a lot
of room to grow. Like AOC was in a similar position and now I
think she's positive nationally.
>> Okay, we've got about 10 minutes left on this. I'm going
to back this up. Oh, uh, stream's about to end. Actually, hold
on. We'll finish this no matter what. But if you guys want more
content, 2 hours in, four subs, I believe. We're four subs away
for two more hours in the stream. Got a minute to get those in.
I'll be right back. I'm going to use the bathroom real quick.
I backed it up a little bit. >> Is he really resonating
with Democrats around the country? Yeah, I'm not so >> Have
you seen evidence? >> Whoever answers polls is the opposite
IRI. They actually he's not as popular national as as he is in
New York. So, >> well, there's a lot of there's a lot of
like undecideds with him. He's unknown and so there's a lot of
room to grow. Like AOC was in a similar position and now I think
he's positive nationally, but at the moment he's down he's like5
nationally, you know, so he's not a particularly popular person
yet. >> Yeah. I'm not saying that he's a known commodity
nationally. I'm saying the race has national attention in a way
that like a normal mayoral race doesn't. And I I do think that
there's an exceptionalism to these major cities. Major cities
that by the way are on the the front of the war against Trump.
What who is Trump, you know, claiming that he wants to you go
into these various cities for? He's doing it in Chicago and New
York City. These places, these major metropolitans, you know,
Gotham City
>> and meet Wad Crusty with a new sub. Okay. One sub away
from two more. Oh my
>> Nope. Nope. Don't sub. Don't sub now. Don't sub now.
Stream ends in 5 minutes. I'm just kidding. I think I honestly
I spent a whole bunch of time preparing a docka for today. You
guys better sub. I better get that last sub right now. >> This
matters. Also, I happen to live here. And um and so yeah, like
the notion that we would have I think Cuomo was like fielding
calls from Trump. He's much more likely to be aligned with Trump.
And in that context, it's not even like a close call for me.
And I think that you could craft a statement such as Soy Bill
gave as an example that would fairly insulate you from any accusation
that you're a socialist. I'm not a socialist. I never been a
socialist. I just defended my boy Econo Boy when he came out.
>> I thought he was I thought he was going to say I just
defend defended my boy Hassan. I thought he was going to say
that for a second, you know, but like
made a little weird given that we know a lot of people have accused
us of being a socialist. Hooligans, thank you for the gifted
sub. That's two hours on the stream. Let's go. >> Pisco
is just he is actually the blue no matter who. I'm pretty sure
which is like the only cringe thing about him. No, there's a
lot of cringe. Never mind. I take it back. Those headphones.
>> You ever see somebody ask him if you >> Yeah,
I have. But those headphones are really [__] cringe
from him. >> Oh, the wired. Nah, >> they fit his
aesthetic.
>> They fit his aesthetic. >> I don't like it. >> I
think they fit. >> And I don't like the pink background.
>> the lighting is done. Get rid of it. >> No, I
think this background looks better than Hutch's. I don't I don't
like Hutch screams from his living room. I like Oh, I don't I
don't like that it's streaming from like his living room. >> Well,
I don't like Hutch's for what Hutch argues for, but that feels
like a very adult background. That's where I want the lawyer
to be sitting. And then I want Hutch in front of the lighting.
>> True. True. >> And then I want Soy Pill off the
screen. >> I I'm not a socialist. I just think that what's
good for the goose is good for the ganter. I don't think really
at the standard for the for the presidential race. If you're
going to say that mom donni shouldn't have to endorse Kla Harris
even though he's an assemblyman in New York, I think he should.
I think he should. I think Assan should have. And I think we
under like when we make it too complicated like well it depends
on the exact intersection between your popularity and how likely
you are to win the race by itself. And then it just to me it
gets too complicated. Man, I just endorse a Democratic candidate.
But I know we have a disagreement and I love you boys. I've always
loved you, boys. >> All right. Well, guys, I think we're
going to wrap up a little bit. >> It's so fake.
Fake at the end. >> I hate when love is a shield for people.
>> Ah, it's uh like slaps these people around and he's
like, "Hey, you know I love you guys. You know I love you guys."
Like the drunk dad getting home at the end of the night in Goodwill
Hunting. Okay. >> He's like taking the belt off and then
afterwards he's like, "You know I love you guys, right?" >> Was
that a part? I watched the movie now. Did it black out that part?
That's when Robin Williams telling Matt Damon >> Oh, he
told the story. Gotcha. Okay. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yep. >> Here.
But I think I I want to add that was that was heated a heated
therapy session for Pisco. And uh as much as I enjoyed it, I
want to end on uh Unity here. And uh I know we weren't going
to make a big deal out of this, but I do want to watch. Did you
guys see >> Donald Trump posting AI videos of
>> Oh [__] >> So So we talked about fascism
and how important it is to mock. Oh, this is the one that people
are off about. He posted like an AI video of medbeds. That's
him speaking and people are like, "Wait, do you think you pass
this law? >> Are you scenile? >> Are you literally
scenile or are you just like posting actual misinformation from
your account as the president? >> You're either lying or
you've lost it. >> You've you're either lying or you're
scenile. Those are the only two options. >> It's no good
option.
Like I that's the crazy part is like I actually don't know that
he knows that it's not him. It's terrifying. >> Fascists.
Um so when when you're president when your fascist authoritarian
crazy leader is uh I guess posting fabricated videos about magical
beds that heal any disease. Um, you know, any and all accusations
that Joe Biden is mentally unfit, I think, are going to fall
out the window or at least should be reciprocated times 5,000
cuz this is insane. >> Breaking now, President Donald J.
Trump has announced a historic new healthare system, the launch
of America's >> Did we watch this on stream or did I watch
it myself? I can't even remember. >> We watched it.
>> I think you showed me this. >> Oh, okay. Wait,
both. >> No, we weren't on stream. first medbed hospitals
and a national medbed card. >> I know yo, full disclosure
for everyone on stream. Full disclosure, this is completely fabricated.
This isn't a real news broadcast. Nothing in this is real. >> Imagine.
So like it's the med beds from like the alien universe. So like
in Prometheus, she went into her little medbed and she had a
little alien abortion. It's like a bed like a theoretical bed
where you it just [__] cures like breaks your it
like heals your broken bone instantly and you know your cancer
cells immediately. It's like Yeah. That's non-existent technology
and obvious AI. >> Actually, even better. Uh Hutch, have
you seen Alissium? I feel like you'd like that film that they
literally had magical beds that cured every disease
>> uh in that one. So anyway, like just to be clear also,
there's no prompt. There's no comment like, you know, I'll be
leading us here in 20 years. Trump healthcare will No, it's just
like unquestioning like this is real, I guess, is how he's posting
this. So, >> every American will soon receive their own
medbed card.
>> That's Yeah. And that's not >> That's not him
saying that. That's a That's an AI. >> Okay. Is there any
more fighting or are they just going to laugh at this meme? Cuz
the meme is funny. Do they Did they not learn about the new one
he just put out today? Oh, they're just laughing. Be happy. I
don't want any more of this.
>> More Hutch on Mom, Donnie. Uh-oh. Teeny Tiny Tony. Uh-oh.
What is this? What is >> Oh my good.
Someone is very excited for the congressional hearing on October
8th. Hutchinson thinks that this time definitely absolutely for
sure will be the end of evil Hassan and Twitch. He even acts
it out for us. Wait, this isn't about Zora Mum Donnie. What the
frame
the wrong tweet although I did see this clip so I'm probably
going to watch it. I Dude, he's so excited for like Han to get
up in front. Okay,
this is literally
like unironically
the person seeing the guy who competed with them to sell like
locks and bagels in little in little Israel, okay, in Germany
celebrating his his competition getting sent to a gas chamber.
That's what he's doing. That's literally what this is, right?
It's literally like, "Oh yeah, Republicans are stomping on Hassan's
uh right to free speech. Oh, that's awesome. I love that. Let's
go." And then in like 3 months when they're sending they're sending
Hutch to the gas chambers too, he's going to be like, "What the
I'm not like them. Why can't I >> And you see Hassan this
entire time like liberals are not understanding what they're
what they've been directing at me is going to come back to them.
>> One of the few times he may be correct.
One of the one of the few Oh my >> Not my boy. >> Let's
listen. Let's listen to Hutch. Hutch is going to be our boy and
argue for why Hassan's first amendment right is not important.
Passan is my boy though. I want that to be clear. >> Is
bad. Oh my goodness, guys. I think that the October hearing in
the oversight committee with those CEOs is going to be so insane.
I stick to my prediction. I think that in the next like 3 weeks,
we're going to see Mum Donnie publicly disavow Hassan [__]
I'm really like very much expecting >> Dude, find something
else to get off on. >> There's no way. There's no way this
guy's sitting here and he's like, "Oh
yeah. Oh,
you're so hot. This about so [__] and I can finish."
Ah, why? What? What the [__] are you doing? Why is
this a thing you think about, bro? Are you >> He is not
good. Do you think that's why his hairstyle is the way that it
is? Is this like um when he's done being this embarrassing thing,
is he just going to go back to his regular hairstyle and shave
the mustache and hope nobody recognizes it? Oh, this is actually
like I you can see it's like a bald cap. You can see like the
lines. You can see the lines of the bald cap right here. This
is actual forehead, but you can see the lines of the bald cap
forming. Okay. He's actually got very long, luscious hair under
this. He's going to pull the the bald cap off. Okay. He's going
to blend into the rest of society.
>> You'll never ever You'll never see it. >> He's
getting paid to be this thing that we're laughing at. >> That
to happen. I think it's going to be a nothing burger. No, definitely
not. that that hearing is gonna be crazy.
I do think so. Yeah. Because they're gonna show I I just we just
know this is gonna happen. Like we know that one or several >> Hadn't
Mark Zuckerberg basically let Cambridge Analytica steal a bunch
of data from Facebook that had turned the 2016 election in Trump's
favor and he went in front of Congress. It was like, "Yeah, this
happened." Yep. And everybody was like, "Oh, Zuckerberg's so
over." And he's still one of the richest like five people on
the planet. Literally did nothing. literally had zero impact
on anything
>> with regards to Zuckerberg and how successful he was.
>> Do they really expect that this is going to go one degree
past and hit Hassan somehow? Like, I'm sorry, congressional hearings
can kind of look bad and there be like a goofy video of you,
but lucky for lucky for Dan Clancy, he doesn't have to make himself
not look like a lizard, okay? Mark Zuckerberg made the mistake
of looking like a android when he went before Congress and not
being able to drink water. Okay, he up in every possible way.
And I don't think Dan Clansancy could do the same thing. I think
Dan Clansancy would be fine. He's like a normal person. Bit of
a pervert, but isn't >> that's their kind. They know. Oh,
are you weird? Are you weird about stuff online? Kind of a predator.
>> Ted Cruz is going to be like, >> we could work
with you. >> That Twitch like story thing. I love that.
Thank you. >> I love that.
I love getting all the hot tub girls all in my feed. Thank you,
Dan. Thank you, class. >> Now, if you're a stand-up citizen
with no flaws, we might have to get you one. >> Oh, sure.
Yeah, >> don't trust that. >> People on that subcommittee
are going to show a montage of clips of Hassan's
greatest hits on Twitch and they're going to, you know, it's
going to end and they're going to be like ah they're going to
totally destroy Hassan's first amendment right. They're going to
[__] him up. Yes. >> Do you have anything to
say for yourself? You do you why do you allow this on your platform?
And I don't know what Clance is going to say. He's going to be
in the hot seat for sure. And there's going to be a ton of pressure
put on Mumani in the closing month of the campaign. >> I
just want to point out again that the actual angle they're pursuing
all of this like through is support for Israel. You just watched
Trump and BB do their joint presentation. You watched Trump secure
the sale of Tik Tok for the sake of pro-Israeli billionaires.
You're watching all of this happen and you're like, "Oh, I love
that we're going to censor pro Palestinian speech on one of the
major platforms. I love that we might get that done. Is this
guy listening to any [__] thing that's happening
and paying any attention whatsoever? I don't think so. I think
he's like totally out to lunch right now. He's totally out to
see. Doesn't know what's going on. He's not paying attention
to address that in one way or another. And so I I think I don't
know if he'll publicly condemn
Assan, but I think we'll see at minimum we'll see a comment like
distancing himself
from Hassan. I I will bet you good money that that's going to
happen. Wow.